Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 20, Query Languages. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. take it away jason hey everybody so i uh i have a decidedly lack of you know knowledge in economics right i mean when it comes to like real uh economics like the equations that go macroeconomics microeconomics i think this would be called uh microeconomics so it's like the strategy behind
主机服务由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 20 集，查询语言。Jason，交给你了。嘿，大家好。交给你了 Jason，嘿，大家好。所以我，呃，我对经济学确实缺乏了解，你知道的，我是说当涉及到真正的经济学，比如宏观经济学、微观经济学中的那些方程时，我想这应该被称为微观经济学，所以它就像是背后的策略。
why people do things like a little bit of game theory, like on the border there. Right. And by the way, by the fact that you said that, I think you just contradicted your first statement. Really? I think that now you've already shown like you were able to determine like what parts and talk about game theory. Oh, I don't know anything about this. All right, go ahead. Well, I may, well, let's just see where the story's going. But basically I, you know, they were talking about at work, they were talking about probability distribution functions and how, like, the distribution can change and now priors and all these things that, like, I had no experience with. Yeah. Okay. So, but statistics in terms of economics, which is, you know, the study of rational people making decisions, right, which is ultimately.
为什么人们会做某些事情，比如博弈论，就在那个边缘。对。顺便说一句，就你刚才说的话，我觉得你刚刚反驳了你自己的第一句话。真的吗？我觉得你现在已经表现出你能够确定哪些部分并谈论博弈论了。哦，我对这个一无所知。好吧，继续吧。嗯，我可能，好吧，让我们看看故事会怎么发展。但基本上，你知道，他们在工作中谈论概率分布函数，以及分布如何变化，还有先验概率以及所有这些我没有经验的事情。是的。好吧。所以，但就经济学而言的统计学，也就是，你知道，研究理性人如何做决策，对吧，这最终是。
In theory. Yeah, exactly. Which is ultimately... In theory. Yeah, exactly. Which is ultimately what everyone's talking about. And I really felt like I was lacking. So I looked up probability distribution function, probability mass function into book search, Google book search. And one of the first results was economics for dummies. And so I was like, well...
理论上。是的，没错。这最终是……理论上。是的，没错。这最终是每个人都在谈论的事情。我真的觉得我很欠缺。所以我查了概率分布函数、概率质量函数，在图书搜索、谷歌图书搜索中。结果中最早的之一就是《经济学傻瓜书》。所以我当时想，嗯……
And I read the like few pages that it gives you of quota or whatever. Before you had to hit the paywall? Yeah, exactly. And I was like, oh, this is, you know, it's a dummies book, but it actually is exactly what I want. It covers everything. And being an economics dummy,
我读了它给你的那几页配额之类的东西。在你必须点击付费墙之前？是的，没错。我当时想，哦，这是，你知道，这是一本傻瓜书，但它实际上正是我想要的。它涵盖了一切。作为一个经济学傻瓜，
I seem like the perfect audience for this book. But then I was like, you know, I want to read the book, but I need it like immediately. And so I was going to order it on amazon things like that but i really needed it like right now i needed it basically in an hour and i was at home so i decided you're really wanting to show show off to your friends at work huh i must learn this overnight i i legitimately i'm gonna go to a bookstore and look for this. Sorry, go ahead. So I went on, you know, our good friends in Sweden who sail the pirate ship. And... The story's getting worse.
我看起来像是这本书的完美受众。但后来我想，你知道，我想读这本书，但我需要立刻读到它。所以我打算在亚马逊上订购它之类的，但我真的现在就需要它，我基本上一个小时内就需要它，而且我当时在家，所以我决定你真的很想在同事面前炫耀，对吧？我必须连夜学会这个。我，我真的要去找一家书店看看有没有这个。抱歉，你继续。所以我去了，你知道，我们在瑞典的好朋友，那些开海盗船的人。而且……故事变得越来越糟了。
I did buy the book, everybody. So the book is on order. But in the meantime... And then I thought, you know... So I looked for a dummies book or whatever. And the first was 547 dummies books. And it was,47 dummies books. And it was like 7 gig.
我确实买了这本书，各位。所以书已经订购了。但与此同时……然后我想，你知道……所以我找了一本傻瓜书之类的。第一个是 547 本傻瓜书。它有 7GB。
And I was like, I got to get this. I mean, like anytime you see like a giant corpus or something. I'm face palming. Just for people who can't see. People who can't see. Patrick is just completely buried in the machine. I am not condoning this behavior at all, Jason. No, do not do this. You have a friend who did this.
我当时想，我必须得到它。我是说，每当你看到像巨大的语料库之类的东西时。我正在扶额。只是为了那些看不见的人。那些看不见的人。Patrick 完全埋头在机器里。我一点也不纵容这种行为，Jason。不，不要这样做。你有一个朋友这么做了。
You did not start this story correctly. That's right. You know this horrible, immoral friend my mate dave don't use names so um so so among the books these are real books that are printed i think addison wesley publishes them for dummies there is pimping for dummies a real book no i i'm not kidding a real book pimping for Dummies, a real book. No. I'm not kidding. A real book, Pimping for Dummies. But there's also like France for Dummies, you know, et cetera. There's tons of these dummies books, you know, Electronics for Dummies,
你这个故事开头没讲对。没错。你知道这个可怕的、不道德的朋友，我的伙伴 Dave，别用名字，所以，嗯，所以，所以这些书里，这些是印刷出来的真书，我想 Addison Wesley 出版了这些傻瓜系列，有一本《拉皮条傻瓜书》，一本真书。不，我，我没开玩笑，一本真书，《拉皮条傻瓜书》，一本真书。不。我没开玩笑。一本真书，《拉皮条傻瓜书》。但还有像《法国傻瓜书》，你知道，等等。有成吨的这种傻瓜书，你知道，《电子学傻瓜书》，
Quantum Mechanics for Dummies, Pregnancy for Dummies. Like that one's probably not necessary, you know. Pregnancy for Dummies should be an empty book, right? But I found one that really resonated yeah so i'm pretty sure this is not true i mean this is a fake book pimping for dummies this is not real oh well they did it in the style of the dummy so somebody must have somebody somebody faked it somebody inject i can actually send you this pdf no i don't want to be a part of this no no don't do that i'm stating now for the record
《量子力学傻瓜书》、《怀孕傻瓜书》。像那本可能没必要，你知道。《怀孕傻瓜书》应该是一本空白的书，对吧？但我发现了一本真正引起共鸣的，是的，所以我很确定这不是真的，我是说这是一本假书，《拉皮条傻瓜书》，这不是真的。哦，好吧，他们是以傻瓜书的风格做的，所以肯定有人，有人伪造了它，有人注入了，我其实可以发给你这个 PDF。不，我不想参与其中。不，不，别那样做。我现在郑重声明，
let the record show the record clearly states patrick does not want the pimp i'm gonna look for it on amazon if it's not amazon it's not real okay someone must have injected this book but um yeah basically uh i found there's hacking for dummies oh nice which is apparently related to pimping for dummies a little bit of everything for dummies oh the little bit of everything is pretty awesome
让记录显示，记录清楚地说明 Patrick 不想要那个拉皮条的。我要去亚马逊上查一下，如果亚马逊上没有，那它就不是真的。好吧，肯定有人注入了这本书，但，嗯，是的，基本上，呃，我发现有《黑客傻瓜书》，哦，不错，这显然和《拉皮条傻瓜书》有点关系，《傻瓜书之万事通》，哦，那个万事通真的很棒。
it's actually chapters taken from other dummies books and seriously like click on that the first chapter is like DOS commands and the second one
它实际上是从其他傻瓜书中摘录的章节，说真的，点击那个，第一章是像 DOS 命令，第二章
is dating or something check this out do you have it anyways I'll keep going look inside so the one that here let's take a look just keep talking or something. Check this out. Okay. I'll keep going. Look inside. The one that... Here, let's take a look.
是约会之类的，看看这个。你有吗？不管怎样，我会继续看里面，所以那个，这里，让我们看看，你继续说或者什么的。看看这个。好吧。我会继续。看里面。那个……这里，让我们看看。
Let's keep talking. The one that really resonated for me among all 500 of them was negotiating for dummies. For some reason, I really... I guess it's because we had actually been talking about negotiating just coincidentally. I mean, some friends the day before.
我们继续说。在所有 500 本书中，真正引起我共鸣的是《谈判傻瓜书》。出于某种原因，我真的……我想是因为我们碰巧一直在谈论谈判。我是说，前一天和一些朋友。
I started flipping through this book and i honestly had very low expectations i mean first of all i i you know didn't really expect to get a whole like economics for dummies like for you to be interested in economics you have to be a little bit of a geek right so the dummies is sort of like a paradox but in the case of you know negotiating for dummies i really thought there would be just really dumb low level like like like you know luddite negotiating for luddites right but but it actually was phenomenal um it starts off the very first section is you know for you to be able to negotiate you have to have like a sense of direction in your life and you have to
我开始翻阅这本书，老实说，我的期望值很低。我是说，首先，我，你知道，并没有真正期望得到一本完整的像《经济学傻瓜书》那样的书，为了让你对经济学感兴趣，你必须有点极客，对吧？所以傻瓜系列有点像个悖论，但在《谈判傻瓜书》的情况下，我真的以为那会是非常愚蠢、低水平的，就像，你知道，卢德分子谈判，对吧？但它实际上非常出色。嗯，它从第一部分开始，你知道，为了能够谈判，你必须在生活中有一种方向感，而且你必须
sort of like know where you're going and that like kind of made sense it's like if you're just getting sort of carried along by life and you don't really have like you don't have like a like a direction or something you want to go to and it's hard for you to really negotiate and so it didn't start with anchoring or don't be the first one to say your goal so yeah it is exactly right it didn't start with any that started with like evaluate your life and that that kind of threw me for a loop is this another fake book no this is totally then it got into pimp now okay but it uh but then no it got into and so it explained cases where you so for example um the you know don't make the first move right
有点知道你要去哪里，这有点道理，就像如果你只是被生活带着走，你真的没有，你没有像一个方向或者你想去的地方，那么你很难真正去谈判，所以它不是从锚定效应或者不要第一个说出你的目标开始的，所以是的，这完全正确，它不是从那些开始的，它从评估你的生活开始，这让我有点措手不及。这是另一本假书吗？不，这完全是，然后它进入了拉皮条，好吧，现在，但它，呃，但后来不，它进入了，所以它解释了一些案例，所以例如，嗯，你知道，不要先出牌，对吧？
it said oh you know a lot of people know know, don't make the first move, right? It said, oh, you know, a lot of people know this, but they accidentally make the first move anyways. And they gave an example. Like, let's say you interview for a job or you're applying for a job. They'll say, you know, put your current pay at your current job. Just leave a blank. Yeah, you don't have to put that. Just put nothing. But then they'll ask you.
它说，哦，你知道，很多人知道，不要先出牌，对吧？它说，哦，你知道，很多人知道这一点，但他们还是不小心先出牌了。他们给了一个例子。比如，假设你去面试一份工作或者你正在申请一份工作。他们会说，你知道，写上你目前工作的薪水。留空就行。是的，你不必写那个。什么都别写。但后来他们会问你。
But you just say, oh, no, thank you. Yeah, you just say, to put that. Just put nothing private. But then they'll ask you, but you just say, oh, no, thank you. Yeah, you just say, look, that information is private. Because by saying what you made your current job, you're effectively making the first move. Like they can guess at like a percentage increase of your current salary. But not to be off track, that's already somewhat. Not making a first move is hard because like if you go to a car dealership, you've made the first move. You showed up at the car dealership. You've already tipped your hand that you're interested in buying that car.
但你只是说，哦，不，谢谢。是的，你只是说，写那个。什么都别写，私人的。但后来他们会问你，但你只是说，哦，不，谢谢。是的，你只是说，看，那是私人信息。因为通过说出你在目前工作赚多少钱，你实际上是在先出牌。就像他们可以猜出你当前薪水的百分比增长。但不要跑题，这已经有点了。不先出牌很难，因为如果你去汽车经销商那里，你就已经先出牌了。你出现在了汽车经销商那里。你已经透露了你有兴趣买那辆车。
As much as you want to feign disinterest, ah, I might buy this car or I might not. You spent your time on time you're not working to go to this place and talk to this person. You've tipped your hand. Or interviewing for a job. If you've bothered to fill out an application form where they had these things, you're already showing that you're somewhat interested. So you've already tipped your hand at some point but what i guess the point is don't tip it more than than you have to like be careful about your information and you might you know you might be willing to work at a place but only for salary x right and
尽管你想假装没兴趣，啊，我可能会买这辆车，也可能不会。你花了你本该工作的时间去那个地方和那个人交谈。你已经透露了你的底牌。或者面试一份工作。如果你费心填写了一份有这些东西的申请表，你已经表明你有点兴趣了。所以你在某个时候已经透露了你的底牌，但我猜重点是不要透露得比你必须透露的更多，比如小心你的信息，你可能，你知道，你可能愿意在一个地方工作，但只为了薪水 X，而且
then they have no way of knowing that that's there's that part of it too right so if you give your current pay let's say you give your current pay, they figure like 99.99% of people would take double their pay. So like that's already information that they know that they wouldn't have known if you didn't put that pay, right? So this is really interesting.
然后他们无法知道这一点，那部分也是如此，对吧？所以如果你给出了你目前的薪水，假设你给出了你目前的薪水，他们会认为 99.99% 的人会接受双倍的薪水。所以这已经是他们知道的信息，如果你不写那个薪水，他们就不会知道，对吧？所以这真的很有趣。
They also covered two things which I thought were really important. One is set limits before you start anything. So before you start negotiating, set a lower and an upper bound, if appropriate. So, you know, clearly you don't want to set an upper bound on your pay. It doesn't make any sense, right? But, you know, set a lower bound, right, or an upper bound on the price of a car, et cetera. Sometimes you need to send a lower and upper bound.
他们还涵盖了两件我认为非常重要的事情。一是开始任何事情之前设定限制。所以开始谈判之前，设定一个下限和上限，如果合适的话。所以，你知道，显然你不想给你的薪水设定上限。这没有任何意义，对吧？但是，你知道，设定一个下限，对吧，或者给汽车的价格设定一个上限，等等。有时你需要设定一个下限和上限。
Or it could be multidimensional negotiation. You should set bounds on all dimensions. And then stick to those the whole way through and remind yourself why you set those. You know, don't let yourself get caught up in the context of the negotiation that, like, you slip on your bounds, right? The other thing is based on the gravity of the decision at every step take a certain amount of time like regardless of any external pressure so for example if you're buying a car yeah they don't like that by the way no no so these are things that the people you're negotiating with will hate you for but these are these these really matter so if you're buying a
或者这可能是多维谈判。你应该在所有维度上设定界限。然后全程坚持这些界限，并提醒自己为什么要设定这些界限。你知道，不要让自己陷入谈判的语境中，以至于你滑向了你的界限，对吧？另一件事是根据决定的重要性，每一步都要花一定的时间，不管有什么外部压力。所以例如，如果你正在买一辆车，是的，顺便说一句，他们不喜欢那样。不，不，所以这些是和你谈判的人会讨厌你的事情，但这些，这些真的很重要。所以如果你正在买一辆
car a car might be let's say like several, maybe a year of your salary, right? Or, like, six months of your salary, some X amount, right? So at least take three days or two days. Every time there's, you know, some shift in the negotiation, take three days and think about it. That seems long. I mean, that's basically it. So, like, when I bought my last car, what happened was we negotiated we got to like a good price or whatever i said i'm gonna go have dinner yeah i did not like that answer like no what i'm gonna put you in it now
车，一辆车可能，比如说，几，也许是你一年的薪水，对吧？或者，比如，你六个月的薪水，某个 X 金额，对吧？所以至少花三天或两天。每次有，你知道，谈判中的某种转变，花三天时间考虑一下。这看起来很长。我是说，基本上就是这样。所以，比如，当我买我上一辆车时，发生的事情是我们谈判，我们谈到了一个好价格之类的，我说我要去吃晚饭。是的，我不喜欢那个答案。不，不，什么，我现在就要让你买。
like the car's gonna sell like all this stuff right i'm like maybe it will yeah i'm like i'm gonna go buy dinner and i'm gonna eat dinner and i'm gonna come back and he's like no no no and i'm like fine like whatever you say like i'm not and then you try to come back. And he's like, no, no, no. And I'm like, fine. Like, whatever you say, like, I'm not. And then he tried to lower the price, right? Like, oh, it was great. Like, I'm writing this down. Like, okay, this is a lower price. Yeah, yeah.
就像车会卖掉一样，所有这些东西，对吧？我当时想，也许会吧。是的，我当时想，我要去买晚饭，我要吃晚饭，然后我要回来。他当时说，不，不，不。我当时说，好吧，随你怎么说，我不是，然后你试着回来。他当时说，不，不，不。我当时说，好吧。随你怎么说，我不是。然后他试着降低价格，对吧？比如，哦，太棒了。比如，我把它写下来。比如，好吧，这是一个更低的价格。是的，是的。
But then I did. I, like, went to dinner and ate about it, talk about it, think about it, clear your head, be away from the high pressure, and then go back. You know, and then just. And just a real-world example. So, obviously, this was before I read the books. This was years ago. But when I went to buy my wife's engagement ring, you know i looked at a bunch of three years salary is that no it's like
但后来我确实这样做了。我，比如，去吃晚饭，边吃边谈，考虑一下，清醒一下头脑，远离高压，然后再回去。你知道，然后只是。只是一个现实世界的例子。所以，显然，这是在我读这些书之前。这是几年前的事了。但当我去给我妻子买订婚戒指时，你知道，我看了很多，三年薪水，不是，那是像
three months or something anyways oh yeah yeah you're right yeah if if my wife is listening several years of salary so so um infinite if you're making no money because you're in school. Very easy. Oh, that's true. Good point. So, you know, I looked at a bunch of rings and I said, you know, I did the right thing, which is to think, you know, spend a couple of days and think about it. And over the course of a couple of days, I realized that I wasn't making a good purchase. Like I had like buyer's remorse, but without buying, right? And so then I went back in sort of with a clear head all over again. And I up saving I think it was like two or three thousand dollars it's like significant you know so I yeah yeah it's pretty
三个月之类的，不管怎样，哦，是的，是的，你是对的，是的，如果，如果我妻子在听，几年的薪水，所以，所以，嗯，无限，如果你没钱，因为你在上学。很容易。哦，那是真的。好观点。所以，你知道，我看了很多戒指，我说，你知道，我做了正确的事，那就是思考，你知道，花几天时间考虑一下。在几天的时间里，我意识到我没有进行一次好的购买。就像我有买家悔恨，但没有买，对吧？所以我又带着清醒的头脑回去了。我最后省下了，我想是两三千美元，这很可观，你知道，所以我，是的，是的，这很
when you're buying a million dollar ring Patrick you don't see me sliding money over to Patrick right now. I'm putting 20s in his pocket consistently. But yeah, the book was Negotiating for Dummies. I wouldn't say it's the best negotiating book because it's only one I've read. But in general, knowing how to negotiate is very important. That's good advice. So did you learn about economics? No, of course not.
当你买一百万美元的戒指时，Patrick，你现在没看到我把钱滑给 Patrick。我一直在往他口袋里塞 20 美元。但是的，那本书是《谈判傻瓜书》。我不会说它是最好的谈判书，因为这是我读过的唯一一本。但总的来说，知道如何谈判非常重要。那是很好的建议。那你学到经济学了吗？不，当然没有。
I was reading about negotiation. No, I did no i did a lot of good economics books it used to be i have like a i like learning new things so i'm constantly changing what i'm interested in so i was interested in economics for a while so i did do some amount of like like online coursework type stuff you know i took micro economics in college and read some books there's like freakonomics was popular that's kind of like short story it's really easy to read it won't teach you about all the economics but some of the kind of that rational thinking how that doesn't always lead you where you think um yeah there's other other books as well so there's a lot of good books out there about that yeah so i mean to answer the question i i you know had to study like bayesian
我读的是关于谈判的内容。不，我没有，我读了很多好的经济学书籍，过去我有一个，我喜欢学习新东西，所以我一直在改变我感兴趣的东西，所以我有一段时间对经济学感兴趣，所以我确实做了一些像在线课程之类的东西，你知道，我在大学里修过微观经济学，读过一些书，有像《魔鬼经济学》很受欢迎，那有点像短篇故事，读起来很容易，它不会教你所有的经济学，但有一些那种理性思维，那种思维并不总是把你带到你认为的地方，嗯，是的，还有其他书，所以有很多关于那方面的好书，是的，所以我是说，回答这个问题，我，你知道，不得不学习像贝叶斯
probabilities and things like that you keep keep saying statistical things, though. Yeah, but I think that there's a high correlation, right? Yeah, I mean, there's a lot of overlap. I guess when you say economics, I think more of like even microeconomics, right? The supply and demand and, you know, pricing and elasticity or inelasticity. So, yeah. I mean, those are like, I don't mean like the statistics are important important as well and i'm sure economists have to be very strong mathematicians for the most part you know um but i i just tend to think more of those or like you said behavioral aspects versus you know it sounds like you approach it for much more of a quantitative yeah exactly yeah
概率之类的事情。你一直在说统计学方面的东西。是的，但我认为它们之间有很高的相关性，对吧？是的，我是说，有很多重叠。我想当你提到经济学时，我更多想到的是微观经济学，对吧？供需，你知道，定价和弹性或非弹性。所以，是的。我是说，那些是，我不认为统计学也很重要，我相信经济学家在很大程度上必须是非常强大的数学家，你知道，嗯，但我，我只是倾向于更多地想到那些，或者像你说的行为方面，而不是，听起来你从更量化的角度来处理它，是的，没错，是的
so i needed it for like for like some very specific things like with respect to like you know equations i was using at work and things like that. And so I think that statistics for dummies probably would have been even better, but I don't think that exists. No, no, no. Not down to your choice. Economics is interesting. But yeah, yeah.
所以我需要它用于一些非常具体的事情，比如关于，你知道，我在工作中使用的方程之类的东西。所以我认为《统计学傻瓜书》可能甚至更好，但我不认为有那本书。不，不，不。不取决于你的选择。经济学很有趣。但是的，是的。
So I mean, I am interested in the other. Actually, one thing which I happened to skim across was a Dutch book. Have you heard of this? Like the language? No. So a Dutch book is when you can set up a set of bets in such a way where you make money regardless of the outcome. So, for example, let's say like you're willing to pay me three dollars to one three to one odds if obama wins the election and i find someone else who's willing to pay three to one if if uh
所以我，我是说，我对另一个感兴趣。其实，我碰巧浏览过的一件事是一本荷兰书。你听说过这个吗？像语言一样？不。所以荷兰书是指当你能以某种方式设置一组赌注，无论结果如何你都能赚钱。所以，例如，假设你愿意付给我三美元对一，三比一的赔率，如果奥巴马赢得选举，我找到另一个人愿意付三比一，如果，呃
mit romney mit romney i didn't know what you were doing okay you forgot the name romney wins the show so much i'm interested in politics right but uh so so if i have two people who are each willing to this is a bookie this is i mean the whole goal of like a las vegas casino in a way well not no no that's much of las vegas because they don't have sports books so like a bookie there's a whole idea right like he tries well sometimes he'll front the money but a lot of times i don't know i don't know that much about it never having gone to one yeah i mean i think the idea is they try to pair up people right like they try to essentially we're betting against each other but they get a cut gotcha for kind of like matching us or whatever but but yeah if you do
米特·罗姆尼，米特·罗姆尼，我不知道你在做什么，好吧，你忘了名字，罗姆尼赢了，节目太多了，我对政治很感兴趣，但，呃，所以，所以如果我有两个人，每个人都愿意，这是一个博彩商，这是，我是说拉斯维加斯赌场的一种目标，嗯，不，不，那不是拉斯维加斯的大部分，因为他们没有体育博彩，所以像博彩商，有一个完整的想法，对吧，就像他尝试，有时他会预付钱，但很多时候，我不知道，我对此了解不多，从来没去过一个，是的，我是说，我认为这个想法是他们试图把人配对，对吧，就像他们试图本质上我们是在互相下注，但他们抽成，明白了，因为某种程度上匹配我们之类的，但，但是的，如果你确实
have this dutch book so you have these two people as i mentioned you can you you're it's in your interest to bet infinity money to both people right because like let's say you bet a thousand dollars um you're gonna lose right because there's two choices and you're betting a thousand dollars on both choices so you're betting two thousand total one because there's two choices, and you're betting $1,000 on both choices. So you're betting $2,000 total. One of those $1,000 you'll lose, and you'll get nothing. The other $1,000 you'll win, and you'll get $3,000. So you'll go from having $2,000 to $3,000 in your pocket. I guess as long as you don't have the whole problem of not being able to pay the one guy
有这本荷兰书，所以你有这两个人，正如我提到的，你，你，对这两个人下注无限的钱符合你的利益，对吧？因为就像假设你下注一千美元，嗯，你会输，对吧？因为有两个选择，而你对两个选择都下注一千美元，所以你总共下注两千，因为有两个选择，而你对两个选择都下注一千美元。所以你总共下注两千美元。那两千美元中的一千你会输掉，你什么也得不到。另外一千你会赢，你会得到三千美元。所以你口袋里的钱会从两千变成三千。我想只要你没有那种无法支付给那个人的整个问题
before you get your other rewards. No, assume that you have the $2,000 up front. And, you know, you're just... It would be infinite money, and then you owe infinite money. Yeah, so... You get infinite knees broken because you can't pay your infinite money. And then it doesn't matter that you have infinite new money because you're laying dead on a street.
在你得到其他奖励之前。不，假设你预先有两千美元。而且，你知道，你只是……那将是无限的钱，然后你欠无限的钱。是的，所以……你会得到无限的膝盖骨折，因为你付不起你的无限钱。然后你是否有无限的新钱并不重要，因为你躺在街上死了。
Maybe you're one of those, like, carrion beetles which have, like, a million legs or whatever. And by the time they break them all, you already have double infinite i say infinite money oh okay uh but this sounds like arbitrage yeah that's the whole idea of arbitrage right a dutch book is this is a situation is a betting or a situation where you could do betting arbitrage and come out ahead okay um with 100 chance of success there's a whole like race to do high frequency trading and underground. New ways of running the cables and fiber optics and microwave towers to communicate between exchanges.
也许你是那种食腐甲虫，有，比如，一百万条腿之类的。等到他们把它们全部折断时，你已经有了双倍无限，我说无限的钱，哦，好吧，呃，但这听起来像套利，是的，这就是套利的概念，对吧？荷兰书是一种情况，是一种博彩或一种情况，你可以进行博彩套利并领先，好吧，嗯，有 100% 的成功机会，有一个完整的，像竞赛一样进行高频交易和地下。运行电缆、光纤和微波塔以在交易所之间通信的新方法。
This is essentially exactly what you said. I know the price in one place, and I know that price is different in another place. And I know in two seconds those prices are going to line back up. But in the meantime, in those two seconds, I can buy a whole bunch from one and sell to the other. And essentially as much stuff as I can transfer between the two before they catch up, I make money. But I, in that process, actually make them catch up.
这本质上正是你所说的。我知道一个地方的价格，我知道那个价格在另一个地方是不同的。我知道两秒钟后这些价格会重新对齐。但与此同时，在那两秒钟内，我可以从一个地方买一大堆，然后卖给另一个。本质上，在它们赶上之前，我能在这两者之间转移多少东西，我就能赚多少钱。但我，在这个过程中，实际上让它们赶上了。
And so I make them catch up faster than they would have before. Because somebody else would have been arbitraging them before and they're slower and I'm faster. So I get that money instead of them. Totally, totally. And then we can, did you hear about this guy? I was a real estate trader. Okay, sorry. He worked for Goldman Sachs.
所以我让它们赶上的速度比以前更快。因为以前会有别人在套利，他们比较慢，而我比较快。所以我得到了那笔钱而不是他们。完全，完全。然后我们可以，你听说过这个人吗？我是一个房地产交易员。好吧，抱歉。他在高盛工作。
He was doing exactly this. So they work on this. Actually, they do this high frequency trading, but it's a lot of like heuristics. They use decision trees and machine learning and stuff to figure out like what to buy and sell and everything. He took his algorithms and he tried to like spin off his own company,
他做的正是这个。所以他们研究这个。其实，他们做这种高频交易，但这是很多像启发式方法。他们使用决策树和机器学习之类的东西来弄清楚买什么和卖什么以及所有东西。他拿了他的算法，他试图，像剥离他自己的公司，
you know, using these algorithms he developed. I think we talked about this, dude. Oh yeah, we did. did on the show he went to jail and everything yeah yeah wow so that guy so we uh so we should probably insert what episode number that was but i don't remember what it was so yeah so if you're watching all the episodes back to back to back then you've just heard this conversation but anyways uh for us it's been years but uh for years but yeah so uh yeah so the economics thing was was interesting the negotiation was very interesting um and in general dummies books are better than i thought i mean i you know they have such a negative connotation right dummies yeah it's like it's like i guess
你知道，使用他开发的这些算法。我想我们谈过这个，伙计。哦，是的，我们谈过。在节目上谈过，他进了监狱之类的，是的，是的，哇，所以那个人，所以我们，呃，所以我们可能应该插入那是哪一集，但我记不清是哪一集了，所以是的，所以如果你正在一集接一集地看所有剧集，那么你刚刚听到了这段对话，但不管怎样，呃，对我们来说，已经过去几年了，但，呃，几年了，但是的，所以，呃，是的，所以经济学的事情很有趣，谈判非常有趣，而且总的来说，傻瓜书比我想象的要好，我是说，我，你知道，它们有如此负面的含义，对吧，傻瓜，是的，就像，就像，我猜
there's some people who like the idea of being a dummy so that was episode two oh wow i thought it has been a really long time former goldman sacks employee jailed eight years for stealing code yeah that was that's been is that two years ago or one year ago here anyways this was march 18th and i didn't write the year it was before years 11 no it's like five billion years um so that was a year and six months ago gotcha gotcha cool but yeah so um dummies books pretty cool especially negotiating for them economics pretty cool economics pretty cool yeah going jail not cool no don't go to jail don't go to jail not hot either okay um on to our news of the week the first article is one I put.
有些人喜欢当傻瓜的想法，所以那是第二集，哦，哇，我以为已经过去很长时间了，前高盛员工因窃取代码被判入狱八年，是的，那是，那是，那是两年前还是前一年，不管怎样，这是 3 月 18 日，我没写年份，那是在 11 年之前，不，那是像 50 亿年，嗯，所以那是一年零六个月前，明白了，明白了，酷，但是的，所以，嗯，傻瓜书很酷，尤其是《谈判傻瓜书》，经济学很酷，经济学很酷，是的，坐牢不酷，不，不要坐牢，不要坐牢，也不热，好吧，嗯，进入我们本周的新闻，第一篇文章是我放的。
So this is a research paper that I thought was pretty cool, mostly just because it's a cool video, I'm not going to lie. It's the equivalent of a cat video, but for programmers, I guess. Nice. And this was somebody, the title was The Floating Point Game of Life, the first headline I saw. But I guess the actual article was something like Continuous Conway's Game of Life or something much more impressive sounding research paper. Just to give you a little bit of hype a little moment both of us looked at
所以这是一篇研究论文，我觉得很酷，主要是因为它是一个很酷的视频，我不会撒谎。它是猫视频的等价物，但对于程序员来说，我想。不错。这是某个人，标题是《浮点生命游戏》，我看到的第一个标题。但我猜实际的文章是像《连续康威生命游戏》之类的，或者听起来更令人印象深刻的研究论文。为了给你一点炒作，一点时刻，我们两个都独立看了
this article independently and we immediately wanted to talk about it's amazing right i was first yeah so i arbitraged yeah i win there's like a dutch book where we're both trying to find articles we were trying to find other people to bet against that we would have this and this. No, okay. So what this was is in Conway's Game of Life, now if you don't recall it by name, is a square grid of squares. And each square can either be occupied or unoccupied. Right.
这篇文章，我们立刻想谈论它，太神奇了，对吧？我是第一个，是的，所以我套利了，是的，我赢了，就像一本荷兰书，我们都在试图寻找文章，我们试图寻找其他人来对赌，我们会拥有这个和这个。不，好吧。所以这是在康威的生命游戏中，现在如果你不记得它的名字，是一个正方形的方格网。每个方格要么被占用，要么未被占用。对。
So alive or dead, essentially. And by a simple set of rules about how many neighbors a cell that neighbor cell up down left right up left down left so yeah nine connectivity or whatever it's called diagonal neighbors or whatever so depending on how many of those cells are occupied means that the cell will either uh become dead from overcrowding will stay alive if it's in the middle numbers or if the cell is already dead and there's enough it will become dead from overcrowding, will stay alive if it's in the middle numbers, or if the cell is already dead and there's enough, it will become alive. Right.
所以活着或死了，本质上。通过一套简单的规则，关于有多少邻居，一个细胞，那个邻居细胞，上、下、左、右、上左、下左，所以是的，九连通性或者不管它叫什么，对角线邻居或者不管什么，所以取决于有多少那些细胞被占用，意味着那个细胞要么，呃，会因为过度拥挤而死亡，如果它在中间数字，它会保持活着，或者如果那个细胞已经死了，并且有足够的，它会因为过度拥挤而死亡，会保持活着，如果它在中间数字，或者如果那个细胞已经死了，并且有足够的，它会变得活着。对。
And so just this simple set of rules, and I forget the exact numbers for each, but having this simple set of rules, you can kind of start with a few, three or four little squares that are alive, and they can just go on for very, very long amounts of time of having this behavior, things growing and exploding and colliding into each other. I mean, we've all, I think, seen these before at one point or another. The gliders, right? There's like gliders, there's blinkers. Takes advantage of the fact that like when you set a cell on, it's not really on in the current state.
所以仅仅是这套简单的规则，我忘记了每个的具体数字，但拥有这套简单的规则，你可以从几个，三四个活着的小方块开始，它们可以持续很长时间，有这种行为，东西生长、爆炸并相互碰撞。我是说，我想我们都曾经在某个时候看到过这些。滑翔机，对吧？有像滑翔机，有闪烁器。利用了这样一个事实，即当你设置一个细胞时，它在当前状态下并不是真的开启。
Because you basically have like a current state and a future state and the future state is independent of each cell is independent of one another right except in their reliance on the previous state right and then so you calculate the future state for all the cells and then you flip the future state becomes the current state right and because of that whole process because of it's that two-stage process you end up yeah with these gliders that are just sort of like well there's all sorts of people made like adding machines. People have made like self-replicating ones. I think someone proved it as Turing Complete or something. I don't know.
因为你基本上有像当前状态和未来状态，未来状态是独立的，每个细胞彼此独立，对吧，除了它们对先前状态的依赖，对吧，然后你计算所有细胞的未来状态，然后你翻转，未来状态变成当前状态，对吧，因为整个过程，因为它是那个两阶段过程，你最终，是的，有了这些滑翔机，它们只是有点，嗯，有各种各样的人制作像加法机。人们制作了像自我复制的。我想有人证明它是图灵完备的或者什么的。我不知道。
Or you probably designed a Turing Complete machine in it is my guess. So there's really a lot of research goes on in there. And it says cellular automata. That's the name. So somebody came up with a research paper where instead of treating it as a discrete square based grid for these things, I think time is still discrete, just like we described, but space is continuous. So each cell, each thing that's alive or dead is an infinitesimally small point. And then it has a neighborhood, which is some radius of circle
或者你可能在里面设计了一台图灵完备的机器，这是我的猜测。所以那里确实有很多研究在进行。它说细胞自动机。那是名字。所以有人想出了一篇研究论文，而不是把它当作离散的基于方格的网格来处理这些东西，我想时间仍然是离散的，就像我们描述的那样，但空间是连续的。所以每个细胞，每个活着或死的东西都是一个无限小的点。然后它有一个邻域，这是一个圆的某个半径
around it. And then essentially created a computer to approximate that by using anti-aliasing and floating point numbers and various things to try to come up with that. And so there's a video that we posted the article, which seemed very technical and complete and only semi-interesting because I'm not that much into research. But the YouTube video
围绕着它。然后本质上创建了一台计算机，通过使用抗锯齿和浮点数以及各种东西来近似它，试图想出那个。所以有一个视频，我们发布了文章，这看起来非常技术性和完整，而且只有半有趣，因为我不太喜欢研究。但 YouTube 视频
is really cool. Yeah, you guys gotta see. And even the song on the YouTube video is awesome. Jason was rocking out to the song. I was totally jammed was totally i listened to it without the music on so i didn't even know it had music i was doing the numa numa dance it was pretty epic hands were waving i don't even know what that was that's that my it's that guy he's like okay no still don't know what it is and for those of you not not watching jason attempt to dance it was pretty embarrassing it was pretty bad yeah there's a lot of empty chairs in this room
真的很酷。是的，你们必须看看。甚至 YouTube 视频上的歌也很棒。Jason 随着那首歌摇摆。我完全沉浸在其中，我完全，我听的时候没有音乐，所以我甚至不知道它有音乐，我正在跳 Numa Numa 舞，这相当史诗，手在挥舞，我甚至不知道那是什么，那是那个家伙，他就像，好吧，不，仍然不知道它是什么，对于那些没有，没有看 Jason 试图跳舞的人来说，这相当尴尬，这相当糟糕，是的，这个房间里有很多空椅子
uh so yeah pretty interesting to check it out but there are a lot of people found the equivalent of gliders but instead of only like i think four directions of the traditional gliders this glider can go in like any direction yeah it's like pairs of gliders that orbit around each other and like these weird like snake support pillar things. Yeah, that was crazy. Yeah. That was interesting. You should check it out. Yeah, it's totally, totally awesome. I think it's a phenomenal idea. It's one of these like, I can't believe I didn't think of it kind of
呃，所以是的，很有趣，去看看，但有很多人发现了滑翔机的等价物，但不是只有，我想传统滑翔机的四个方向，这个滑翔机可以朝任何方向走，是的，就像成对的滑翔机围绕着彼此旋转，还有这些奇怪的像蛇一样的支撑柱东西。是的，那太疯狂了。是的。那很有趣。你应该去看看。是的，它完全，完全棒极了。我认为这是一个非凡的想法。这是那种，我不敢相信我没想到的那种
things. It's like such a awesome idea. And to think that the Game of Life has been around for what, 50 years or something like that? A long time. Yeah. We recently had the 50 year anniversary. Oh no, it was 1970. So, actually it is close to 50 years or something like that. Yeah. It recently had the 50-year anniversary. Oh, no, it was 1970. Actually, it is close to 50 years.
事情。这就像一个如此棒的想法。而且想到生命游戏已经存在了，什么，50 年左右？很长一段时间。是的。我们最近举行了 50 周年纪念。哦，不，那是 1970 年。所以，实际上它接近 50 年左右。是的。它最近举行了 50 周年纪念。哦，不，那是 1970 年。实际上，它接近 50 年。
It's not quite 50 years. You're a little early. Yeah, a little early. But, yeah, totally awesome. Oh, here's in Minecraft somebody built Conway's Game of Life. Do people do everything in Minecraft? No, I have to watch this video. Did you see that the game of life
还没到 50 年。你有点早了。是的，有点早。但，是的，完全棒极了。哦，这是在 Minecraft 中，有人建造了康威的生命游戏。人们在 Minecraft 中做所有事情吗？不，我必须看这个视频。你看到生命游戏了吗
was actually in the search did you see that or is that just me do the search again okay hang on i'm watching the video oh yeah yeah here we see you made an amazing thing oh it is wow somebody made conway's game of life in minecraft no when you had exactly what you expected to look like when you had the search results it actually looked like there was Game of Life going. Oh, in the background? In the background. But I might have just been looking that up. Oh, yeah.
实际上在搜索中，你看到了吗，还是只有我？再做一次搜索，好吧，等等，我正在看视频，哦，是的，是的，在这里我们看到你做了一件了不起的事情，哦，它是，哇，有人在 Minecraft 中制作了康威的生命游戏，不，当你拥有你期望它看起来完全像什么时，当你得到搜索结果时，它实际上看起来好像生命游戏正在进行。哦，在背景中？在背景中。但我可能只是在查那个。哦，是的。
Yeah, yeah. That's pretty cool. So my article is not as cool, unfortunately. I kind of, you know, I wish I could do, you know, crazy continuous integration, Riemann sum, game of life thing with floating point. But I think it's still pretty cool. So Twitter, they bought a company called Clutch.io. And Clutch.io does A-B testing for mobile.
是的，是的。那很酷。所以我的文章没那么酷，不幸的是。我有点，你知道，我希望我能做，你知道，疯狂的连续集成，黎曼和，带浮点的生命游戏。但我认为它仍然很酷。所以 Twitter，他们买了一家叫 Clutch.io 的公司。Clutch.io 为移动设备做 A-B 测试。
And I'll get into A-B testing in a minute. But Twitter was fortuitous, or we are fortuitous, or something. I don't know where you're. But Twitter was fortuitous, or we are fortuitous, or something. I don't know where you're going. It is fortuitous that Twitter open-sourced the Clutch.io library for everyone to use.
我一会儿会讲到 A-B 测试。但 Twitter 是偶然的，或者我们是偶然的，或者什么的。我不知道你在哪里。但 Twitter 是偶然的，或者我们是偶然的，或者什么的。我不知道你要去哪里。Twitter 将 Clutch.io 库开源供所有人使用是偶然的。
So what is A-B testing? Patrick. What is A-B testing? Thank you. Jason, tell me. I've heard this term before, and I just can't figure out what it means. Could you help me?
那么什么是 A-B 测试？Patrick。什么是 A-B 测试？谢谢。Jason，告诉我。我以前听过这个词，我就是搞不懂它是什么意思。你能帮我吗？
A-B testing for dummies. Let me look. So A-B testing comes from alpha-beta testing, and alpha-beta is a type of distribution. First two letters of the Greek alphabet? That's true, too. But alpha-beta is a type of... Oh, ab-improving muscle training for dummies?
《A-B 测试傻瓜书》。让我看看。所以 A-B 测试来自 alpha-beta 测试，而 alpha-beta 是一种分布类型。希腊字母表的前两个字母？那也是真的。但 alpha-beta 是一种……哦，傻瓜腹肌训练？
Alpha beta is a type of probability distribution. And it might be that if you're at economics for dummies, it would go into what alpha beta filters are. But anyways, so alpha beta testing is super important if really, I mean, you're in any type of industry and the idea is you have a you know your alpha which is sort of your control group then you have beta which is you know some new feature so for example you might have let's say your website is a cars that you're trying to sell or something like that so you might have an alpha group which has your website as it exists now. Then you might have a beta group where you randomly
Alpha beta 是一种概率分布类型。如果是在《经济学傻瓜书》里，它可能会深入探讨什么是 alpha beta 过滤器。但不管怎样，所以 alpha beta 测试非常重要，如果真的，我是说，你在任何类型的行业，这个想法是你有一个，你知道你的 alpha，也就是你的控制组，然后你有 beta，也就是，你知道一些新功能，所以例如，你可能有，假设你的网站是你试图卖的汽车之类的东西，所以你可能有 alpha 组，它有你现在存在的网站。然后你可能有 beta 组，在那里你随机
throw in high-priced cars. So it's like, oh, I searched for Volvo. I searched for whatever. But I'm going to randomly throw in something which kind of matches the search result, but also more expensive. And the idea is maybe you make a commission off expensive cars. so even like you know so your alpha version like I said gives the gives the users exactly what they want the beta vision version gives them what
扔进高价车。所以就像，哦，我搜索了沃尔沃。我搜索了什么。但我会随机扔进一些与搜索结果有点匹配，但也更贵的东西。这个想法是也许你从昂贵的汽车中赚取佣金。所以即使像，你知道，所以你的 alpha 版本，就像我说的，给用户他们想要的，beta 版本给他们他们想要的，但也扔进一些这些昂贵的汽车，然后你可以独立查看这两者的结果，你可以看到，哦，你知道，当人们到达网站的 beta 版本时，他们确实花了更多的钱，他们买了更贵的车，但他们再也没回来之类的。所以就像，好吧，长期来看，这会伤害我的生意。所以我需要坚持我的 alpha 版本。即使它写着 alpha beta，实际上，你可以以多种不同的方式拆分。所以你可以有，你知道，八个变化。现在你有 256 种不同版本的网站。
they want but also throws in some these expensive cars then you can look at the results of both of these independently and you can see oh you know when I when when people got to the beta version of the website, they did spend more money and they bought more expensive cars, but they never came back or something like that. And so it's like, well, long term, this is going to hurt my business. So I need to stick with my alpha version. Even though it says alpha beta, in reality, you can split many different ways. So you could have, you know, eight changes. And now you have two to the eight different versions of your website there's a 256
他们想要的，但也加入了一些昂贵的汽车，然后你可以独立查看这两者的结果，你会发现，哦，你知道，当人们进入网站的测试版时，他们确实花了更多的钱，买了更贵的车，但他们再也没有回来过之类的。所以这就像是，从长远来看，这会损害我的业务。所以我需要坚持使用我的 Alpha 版本。尽管它被称为 Alpha 和 Beta，但实际上，你可以通过多种方式进行拆分。所以你可以有，你知道，八种变化。现在你有 2 的 8 次方种不同版本的网站，也就是 256 种。
different versions of your website and you can you know sort of isolate which version is the best like which features helped which features hurt so this sounds easy it's actually really hard I mean one of the things that makes it hard is being consistent So you have to find some way to know okay Patrick visits my site He's getting the B version of the site a week later when he comes back He needs to get the same B version like if every time you refresh the page you get either one version or the other That's gonna be really confusing and it's gonna pollute. You know your experiment
不同版本的网站，你可以隔离出哪个版本最好，比如哪些功能有帮助，哪些功能有负面影响。这听起来很简单，但实际上非常难。我的意思是，难点之一在于保持一致性。你必须找到某种方法来确定，比如 Patrick 访问了我的网站，他看到的是 B 版本，一周后他再回来时，他看到的必须还是同一个 B 版本。如果每次刷新页面看到的版本都不一样，那会非常令人困惑，而且会污染你的实验数据。
so the other that's going to be really confusing and it's going to pollute you know your experiment so ab testing frameworks for the web or in this case for mobile sort of deal with that and they hash users in such a way where they you know they keep it consistent they give good reporting and all that good stuff so if you do any development you want to be using an ab testing and if you're doing mobile you should check out this one open source by Twitter. That's cool. Yeah, I mean, it's a lot of people doing, especially e-commerce, like if you sell something, right? A-B testing is really important.
所以，这会非常令人困惑，而且会污染你的实验。因此，网页版（或者在这种情况下是移动端）的 A/B 测试框架通常会处理这个问题。它们通过某种方式对用户进行哈希处理，从而保持一致性，并提供良好的报告等等。所以如果你在做开发，你应该使用 A/B 测试；如果你在做移动端开发，你应该看看 Twitter 开源的这个工具。那很酷。是的，很多人都在用，尤其是电子商务，如果你在卖东西，对吧？A/B 测试非常重要。
Yeah, definitely. Is the red buy button or the green buy button better? Well, exactly. You know, you could guess, but in reality, it's better to try to test. Yeah, totally. Actually, I heard from a friend of mine who works at a startup
是的，绝对是。红色的购买按钮还是绿色的购买按钮更好？嗯，确实。你知道，你可以猜，但实际上，最好还是通过测试来验证。是的，完全同意。其实我听一个在创业公司工作的朋友说
who was telling me of another startup that makes Facebook games. And they had this one Facebook game that was like a fish. It was like an aquarium. And you pay real money to get food for your aquarium or whatever. And they weren't doing alpha beta testing. They added this feature where basically you could buy something that you couldn't buy before. So there was something before that you could only get through experience in the game right it was like maybe like your fish could grow up or something all of a sudden they added this thing where you could pay like a dollar
他跟我提到另一家做 Facebook 游戏的创业公司。他们有一个 Facebook 游戏，就像养鱼一样。就像一个水族馆。你花真钱给你的水族馆买鱼食之类的。他们当时没有做 A/B 测试。他们增加了一个功能，基本上就是你可以买到以前买不到的东西。以前有些东西只能通过在游戏中积累经验获得，比如你的鱼可能会长大之类的。突然间，他们加了一个功能，你可以花一美元
and have adult fish immediately i don't know i'm making this up but you get the idea like they added some monetization strategy that wasn't there and everybody left. Like it compromised everything. And I think for some reason it's like, people felt like having an adult fish was like a rite of passage almost. And by making it to where you could pay at like essentially trivial amount of money for something that took hundreds of hours
然后让鱼立刻长大。我不知道，我这是编的，但你明白我的意思。他们增加了一种以前没有的变现策略，结果所有人都走了。这破坏了一切。我觉得某种程度上，人们觉得养大一条鱼就像是一种成人礼。而通过让你花一点点钱就能得到原本需要数百小时
of real like effort to do before, it like ruined the entire game. And actually the company literally went out of business people say that about the new diablo because you can play the game and get a really good artifact a sword or whatever i don't remember the name and then sell it on the internal auction house and make money that like it becomes like almost like a job like you want to play because you want to you know get this thing so you can make more money by selling it. And some people have said that's ruined. Other people have said it's great and you make money.
才能获得的成就，这毁了整个游戏。事实上，那家公司真的倒闭了。人们对新版《暗黑破坏神》也有类似的评价，因为你可以玩游戏获得非常好的神器，比如一把剑之类的，我不记得名字了，然后可以在内部拍卖行卖掉赚钱。这变得几乎像一份工作，你想玩是因为你想获得这个东西，这样你就可以通过卖掉它来赚更多的钱。有些人说这毁了游戏，另一些人说这很棒，你可以赚钱。
But it's true. I think it's hard to do A-B testing, though, with something like that because when you're rolling it out to things that are naturally shared or social or community-driven, if you A-B test, I don't know that that works. So you could A-B test the sign-up page or something. But the actual thing, if I give you free fish and i don't get free fish like or you know sally doesn't get free fish like so this is confusing so like you're not only interesting topic actually so i know that the way i have so i know the way that they do this right now is actually through country so i have
但确实如此。我觉得用这种方式做 A/B 测试很难，因为当你把它推广到那些天生具有共享、社交或社区驱动属性的事物时，我不确定 A/B 测试是否有效。你可以对注册页面之类的进行 A/B 测试，但对于实际内容，如果我得到了免费的鱼，而你没有，或者 Sally 没有，这会很混乱。所以这不仅是一个有趣的话题，而且我知道他们现在做这件事的方法其实是通过国家/地区。所以我
another friend who works at a uh social startup i have like a lot of social startup friends um this one they actually test everything in canada so they do for them to do out the way they do ab testing is they do the b and b stuff in canada and of course there's skew there because canadians probably have different yeah well this is how like restaurants do like if you ever i don't know if you've ever been to a restaurant when they're testing a new product or something and they'll just like serve you a special product just there. Only that store has that feature. And then, you know, they see how people like it or not. That's a little different than A-B testing. Because A-B is supposed to be kind of like completely independent. Like I'm picking random people across my whole entire population. That's true. And I'm giving them some feature and seeing if they react differently.
有另一个在社交创业公司工作的朋友，我有好多做社交创业的朋友。他们实际上是在加拿大测试所有东西。他们做 A/B 测试的方式就是把 B 版本放在加拿大测试。当然，这会有偏差，因为加拿大人可能……是的，这就像餐馆的做法。如果你去过一家餐馆，他们正在测试新产品，他们只会给那家店的顾客提供特殊产品。只有那家店有那个功能。然后他们看看人们喜不喜欢。这和 A/B 测试有点不同，因为 A/B 测试应该是完全独立的。比如我从整个人群中随机抽取用户，
Yeah, I mean ideally... Because you get all these other bugs. Like if you do it in Canada, like, oh, I'm randomly selecting everybody in Canada. Oh, okay, but you're introducing all sorts of biases. Yeah, totally. I mean, something that would be amazing would be if you like took your users,
给他们提供某种功能，看看他们的反应是否不同。是的，我的意思是理想情况下……因为你会遇到各种其他错误。比如如果你在加拿大做，你会想，哦，我是在随机选择加拿大的所有人。哦，好吧，但你引入了各种各样的偏差。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，如果能把你的用户，
you know, let's say you're making some social app, whatever, looked at the social structure like look at the the structure of the relationships between those users and broke them up into like connected components to do a b testing um that would be pretty awesome i mean so you can't be perfect because it'll be like ultimately they'll always be these two people who are friends and are on different versions right unless you literally have two disjoint communities. But chances are you won't, right? Because people refer their friends and things like that. But maybe you could find these pockets
比如你正在做一个社交应用，观察用户之间的社交结构，并将他们分成连通分量来进行 A/B 测试，那会非常棒。我的意思是，你不可能做到完美，因为最终总会有两个朋友处于不同的版本中，除非你拥有两个完全不相交的社区。但这种情况不太可能，对吧？因为人们会推荐朋友之类的。但也许你可以找到这些
where there's very few connections out and you could A-B test. That could be the B pocket. Yeah, I think A-B testing is typically or maybe even fundamentally supposed to be small changes. Like minor things, not like large features or the color of a button or the placement of something on a page or small stuff like that. So we've talked multiple times about just stating the obvious. That's my new thing, state obvious things.
连接很少的孤岛，然后进行 A/B 测试。那可以作为 B 组。是的，我认为 A/B 测试通常或者说从根本上应该是针对小的改动。比如微小的调整，而不是大型功能，或者按钮的颜色、页面上某个东西的位置之类的小事。所以我们已经多次讨论过陈述显而易见的事实了。这是我的新爱好，陈述显而易见的事情。
All right, cool. You got that for dummies, the state obvious things for dummies? Talking for dummies? So Coursera is one of the online education platforms. And I actually happened to be involved in this. Oh, that sounds bad. I knew that this had happened before the news broke.
好吧，酷。你有那个“傻瓜式陈述显而易见的事情”吗？“傻瓜式谈话”？Coursera 是在线教育平台之一。我其实碰巧参与了这件事。哦，那听起来很糟糕。我在新闻爆出之前就知道这件事发生了。
So basically, the inventor of the Scala language, which Scala we haven't talked about before, but is a functional programming language built on top of the Java virtual machine. He is offering a functional programming class for free on Coursera. So I'd signed up for this class, you know, in the high-hoping dreams that I would have time to watch the videos and do the exercises. And pretty much like every other class I've taken online for free, I just have no motivation to actually do it. I get busy. But I got this email one day saying that basically they had detected cheating
基本上，Scala 语言的创始人（我们之前没谈过 Scala，但它是一种构建在 Java 虚拟机之上的函数式编程语言）正在 Coursera 上免费提供一门函数式编程课程。所以我报名了这门课，怀着我会有时间看视频和做练习的梦想。但就像我参加过的其他所有免费在线课程一样，我根本没有动力去完成它。我太忙了。但有一天我收到一封邮件，说他们检测到了作弊行为
in this online course. Wow. So this is a couple of interesting things. One, it's a fully optional and free online course with no college credit, just like some email saying you complete this course as the only output. Why do need to cheat just be like me just don't do anything like it isn't it doesn't really like i don't resume padding or something right but i don't like it doesn't have a lot of value for a resume at this point like maybe one day it will i guess but then just don't take it now like i don't you know and there's no association like it's just your email right so you could just
在这门在线课程中。哇。这有几点很有趣。第一，这是一门完全可选的免费在线课程，没有大学学分，唯一的产出就是一封邮件说你完成了这门课。为什么要作弊呢？像我一样什么都不做不就行了吗？它在简历上也没什么价值，也许有一天会有，但现在就别选了。而且它没有任何关联，只是你的邮箱而已，所以你可以
change use a different email next time or whatever. I don't think it's a super big deal. But people were still cheating. They had basically posted solutions to some of the programming problems online. And this is kind of confusing slash also disheartening. And so they said that, oh, we've tried to identify the people who did this. We're going to basically block them. We're going to kind of give zeros to the people.
下次换个邮箱之类的。我觉得这没什么大不了的。但人们还是在作弊。他们基本上把一些编程问题的答案贴到了网上。这让人感到困惑，同时也令人沮丧。所以他们说，哦，我们已经试图找出那些作弊的人。我们要封禁他们，给他们零分。
Or I forget exactly the action they were going to, you know, basically block them. We're going to kind of like give zeros to the people. I forget exactly the action they were going to take. But people like submitted assignments that were exact copies of the online known ones. And then like, oh, they're going to have the TAs basically looking online for, you know, solutions to pop up. Because arguably most people just find this by Google searching. Like, oh, folks are performing class. Oh, here's a form. Oh, look, here's the answers.
或者我不记得他们具体要采取什么行动了，基本上就是封禁他们，给他们零分。我不记得具体行动了。但人们提交的作业和网上已知的答案完全一样。然后助教们基本上会在网上搜索，看看有没有答案冒出来。因为可以说大多数人只是通过谷歌搜索找到的。比如，哦，函数式编程课。哦，这里有个论坛。哦，看，这里有答案。
How nice. But it does bring up an interesting thing that, again this is a free class like no i'll be but people still like feel compelled to cheat and like try to get around doing real work which is kind of sad did the article go into why people no i mean nobody knows right like you can't you can make guesses or psychologists or whatever but i mean the other thing is like if my question was just like i guess maybe different maybe because the stakes are higher i don't know but like if you go to university so nobody ever talks about like cheating at university sometimes they do talk about cheating at university level there was somebody in my lab so many phd students they are also tas right for classes um that's sort of what pays the bills while you're in grad school um he actually wrote
真好。但这确实引出了一个有趣的问题，再次强调，这是一门免费课程，但人们仍然觉得有必要作弊，试图绕过真正的努力，这有点可悲。那篇文章有没有提到为什么？不，没人知道，对吧？你可以猜测，或者心理学家可以猜测，但我的意思是，如果我的问题是……我猜也许是因为风险更高，我不知道。但如果你去上大学，没人会谈论大学里的作弊，有时他们会谈论大学层面的作弊。我实验室里有人，很多博士生也是课程助教，这在读研期间是维持生计的方式。他实际上写了
a program to do like like semantic analysis of your code, like to generate the tree, the call tree and all that. And he somehow was able to write a program to detect copies. And then he just ran it on all N squared pairs of, you know, students assignments and found out groups of them, like, you know, these nine people all have exactly the same answer. And so I think it's possible. So, okay, so I'm not saying it's not possible to detect the cheating. I'm just saying, like, there's a lot of high stakes. Like, if people are cheating in online free classes with, like, basically low stakes,
一个程序来进行代码的语义分析，比如生成调用树之类的。他不知怎么写了一个程序来检测抄袭。然后他在所有学生作业的 N 平方对组合上运行了这个程序，发现了一些群体，比如这九个人都有完全相同的答案。所以我认为这是可能的。所以，我不是说检测作弊是不可能的。我只是说，风险很高。如果人们在风险很低的免费在线课程中作弊，
and now the stakes are higher. You've paid money to take this class. It is going on your resume. Are you going to graduate in time? Like, the bar to, to like fail is so much higher so arguably maybe people don't want to cheat because if you get caught cheating like it's much more much more damaging but it's an interesting question and there have been cases like recently of kids cheating in high school like taking sat tests for each other oh yeah and people doing
而现在风险更高了。你付钱参加了这门课，它会写在你的简历上。你能按时毕业吗？失败的门槛高得多，所以可以说人们可能不想作弊，因为如果被抓到作弊，后果会严重得多。但这是一个有趣的问题，最近确实有高中生作弊的案例，比如互相代考 SAT。哦，是的，还有人们进行
electronic cheating i oh i could have put this article in here i was reading this article the other day about somebody cheating in chess and just like, oh. Did we talk about that last time? I don't remember. I don't think so. Yeah, so like there was a kid basically using like a PDA. So they have some specific model of PDA,
电子作弊。我本可以把那篇文章放进来的，我前几天读到一篇关于某人在国际象棋中作弊的文章，就像，哦。我们上次谈过这个吗？我不记得了。我觉得没有。是的，有个孩子基本上在使用 PDA。他们有一种特定的 PDA 型号，
which I'm not very familiar with chess competitively. Whatever competitive chess associate has like a specific model of PDA that runs a specific app that's allowed. It's to keep notes. It's very traditional when you play chess that you keep notes about all the moves of the game so you can analyze it later. Or analyze famous chess masters
我对竞技国际象棋不太熟悉。无论竞技国际象棋协会有什么规定，他们有一种特定的 PDA 型号，运行特定的允许使用的应用程序。它是用来记笔记的。下国际象棋时记下所有走法以便以后分析是非常传统的。或者分析著名国际象棋大师的
games. These kinds of things. They said, we'll just let these people use this app on this specific PDA, not like an iPhone or something general. That app's developer has promised like, oh, it locks everything out. It's the only app that can be running. We don't allow multitasking. We turn off all the Wi-Fi, everything, right?
比赛。这些事情。他们说，我们只允许这些人在这款特定的 PDA 上使用这个应用程序，而不是像 iPhone 之类的通用设备。该应用程序的开发者承诺，哦，它锁定了所有东西。它是唯一可以运行的应用程序。我们不允许后台多任务处理。我们关闭了所有 Wi-Fi，所有东西，对吧？
Like it's all turned off. But there's now the ability for even these small devices to run very high quality chess engines, right? So they don't know exactly what happened, but all of a sudden this kid who was really bad started doing really good and like somebody came over and noticed him doing something
就像所有东西都关掉了。但现在即使是这些小设备也有能力运行高质量的国际象棋引擎，对吧？所以他们不知道到底发生了什么，但突然间这个原本很差的孩子开始表现得非常好，有人走过去注意到他在用他的设备做一些
fishy with his with his device but they didn't confiscate it they didn't look at it they didn't like it just kind of let it go so they don't have any like clue about kind of what to do but it kind of brought into this like oh people cheating at chess you know but like brings in this general like electronic cheating like other people have been found with like little tiny like micro speakers in their ears like really hidden ones down in their ears getting told chess moves with somebody else basically doing it on a laptop right and like playing the opponent's moves and then letting the you know computer like all these things like all these you know high-tech cheating now is gonna be a real problem like how to detect it
可疑的事情，但他们没有没收它，没有检查它，只是放过了。所以他们没有任何线索该怎么办，但这引出了“哦，人们在国际象棋中作弊”的话题。这引出了普遍的电子作弊问题，其他人被发现耳朵里藏着微型扬声器，非常隐蔽，有人在笔记本电脑上操作，告诉他们国际象棋的走法，基本上是让电脑来下棋。所有这些高科技作弊现在将成为一个真正的问题，如何检测它，
to deal with it to stop it that's really interesting so i yeah i don't know so i mean like you said one thing is like you can compare so they do this for research paper or not research but like oh yeah turn it in right yeah there's like various services where basically you upload or all your students upload their research papers right but not like not like PhD research papers. For people who don't know, turnitin.com is a website. Like many TAs and teachers use it. Basically, it's this huge repository of, you know, research papers. I think it just scans like tons of things,
如何处理它，如何阻止它。这真的很有趣。所以我不知道。我的意思是，就像你说的，一种方法是比较，他们对研究论文做这个，或者不是研究论文，哦，是的，Turnitin 对吧？是的，有各种服务，基本上你上传或者所有学生上传他们的研究论文，但不是博士研究论文。对于不知道的人来说，Turnitin.com 是一个网站。很多助教和老师都在用它。基本上，它是一个巨大的研究论文库。我想它扫描了大量的东西，
like mine's Google Scholar and like all these things. And basically it looks for, so then when you submit an assignment, it looks for plagiarism. So it looks for plagiarism between you and other research papers. Right. And also you from like it has repositories of books and articles and web pages and like all this stuff.
比如谷歌学术之类的。基本上，当你提交作业时，它会查找抄袭。所以它会查找你和其他研究论文之间的抄袭。没错。而且它还有书籍、文章和网页的存储库，所有这些东西。
And so it'll show like, oh, this whole section is matched. And, you know, whether or not like it's annotated or footnoted or quoted or whatever. So basically give you a score of how likely it is this person cheated or how much they cheated. Right. But then for like code, it's actually fairly straightforward. So for words, it's pretty hard. Like you'd have to restate it. But if you're going to take time to restate a whole paper and like change all the words
所以它会显示，哦，这一整段都匹配。无论它是否被标注、引用或引用了。所以基本上给你一个分数，说明这个人作弊的可能性有多大，或者他们作弊的程度。没错。但对于代码来说，这其实相当简单。对于文字来说，这很难。你必须重写它。但如果你要花时间重写整篇论文，改变所有的词汇，
around so it still makes good English sense, but you know, it's different enough. Like you might as well just write the research paper from scratch. It's kind of a lot of work because you have to understand the material, which is arguably the point anyways. But for a programming assignment, you have to understand the material, which is arguably the point anyways. But for a programming assignment, you can just, for instance, like rename all the variables. Yeah. And then it would be very hard to detect that in this. So you say like, you know, you knew this person who wrote like, analyze the tree.
让它仍然符合英语逻辑，但足够不同。你还不如从头开始写这篇研究论文。这需要很多工作，因为你必须理解材料，这本来就是重点。但对于编程作业，你必须理解材料，这本来就是重点。但对于编程作业，你可以，例如，重命名所有的变量。是的。然后就很难检测到了。所以你说，你知道那个写分析树程序的人。
So we're going to have to go to stuff like that. But then people are going to know that's the case. So then they'll have a, they'll add an extra program that, yeah, add an extra function, add a program that permutes, you know, it's like alters the function the function calling or you know adds extra extraneous ones that don't matter right and then it'll just be this cat and mouse game yeah totally it always ends up like an arm race like all this stuff like spam finding spam you know botnets like stopping now but it always ends up like some arm arms race or like you figure out a way to filter it and they figure out what to get around the filter and then it keeps going yeah this will be another one of those
所以我们必须转向类似的方法。但人们会知道这一点。所以他们会添加一个额外的程序，添加一个程序来置换函数调用，或者添加一些无关紧要的额外代码，然后这就变成了一场猫鼠游戏。是的，完全正确。它总是以军备竞赛告终，就像所有这些事情一样，垃圾邮件、僵尸网络，阻止它们，但它总是变成某种军备竞赛，或者你找到一种过滤方法，他们找到绕过过滤的方法，然后它就一直持续下去。是的，这将是其中之一。
yeah actually i saw an interesting ted talk on cheating this was a while ago like three or four years ago but one of the cool things was everybody has sort of like uh an internal like i don't know what to call it but like basically like like so the example he gave was in one case if you cheated there was a way for you to cheat but there wasn't a large gain in the other case there's a way for you to cheat and the gain was larger and it turns out like a lot more people cheated oh and the thing I didn't explain in both cases it was trivial to cheat and you knew you weren't gonna get caught so you know a robot
是的，其实我看过一个关于作弊的有趣的 TED 演讲，那是很久以前了，大概三四年前，但其中很酷的一点是，每个人都有某种内在的……我不知道该怎么称呼它，但基本上……所以他给出的例子是，在一种情况下，如果你作弊，有一种作弊方式，但收益不大；在另一种情况下，有一种作弊方式，收益更大。结果发现，更多的人作弊了。哦，我没解释的是，在这两种情况下，作弊都很简单，而且你知道你不会被抓到。所以，你知道，一个机器人，
you know just a naive like you know math model of this would just say there's no chance of getting caught there's no implications i should cheat regardless of you know of of the game but the reality is people have this like internal inertia against cheating or like an internal karma system but if the reward is big enough they'll cheat and i thought that was really interesting would have been more interesting well i is the experiment if they had actually cheated when the stakes were less like somehow being worried that when the stakes are higher that the penalty would be somehow implicitly higher oh yeah but the way the experiment was structured it was obvious that there was no penalty yeah like completely obvious
一个天真的数学模型会说，没有被抓到的机会，没有后果，所以我应该作弊，不管收益如何。但现实是，人们对作弊有一种内在的惯性，或者一种内在的业力系统，但如果奖励足够大，他们就会作弊。我觉得这非常有趣。如果他们能在风险较小的时候作弊，那就更有趣了。某种程度上担心风险越高，惩罚也会隐性地更高。哦，是的，但实验的结构很明显，没有惩罚。是的，完全明显。
but yeah that's interesting too like because what you described seems rational like okay so like if there's no chance of getting caught right and people will cheat but if the stakes aren't that big like what does it matter like i'm just not gonna cheat it's true i mean it's interesting but yeah yeah that's a bash on your video no no i just it's it's it's interesting it's sort of like cheating has like a weight to it it's sort of like cheating has like a weight to it it's sort of like if there's not a lot of gain then i don't want like the bad karma of cheating is basically that's what i took away from it you know but the same the same guy had this interesting thing where uh if you're given three choices and um all three are of roughly
但这也很有趣，因为你描述的似乎很理性。好吧，如果没有被抓到的机会，人们就会作弊，但如果风险没那么大，那又有什么关系呢？我只是不会作弊。这是真的，我的意思是，这很有趣，但……是的，那是对你视频的抨击。不，不，这很有趣，作弊似乎有一种分量。我的意思是，如果收益不大，我就不想背负作弊的坏业力，这基本上就是我从中得到的结论。但同一个人还有一个有趣的事情，如果你有三个选择，而且
like the same quality or maybe you don't even know their quality but or no sorry I got it wrong you have two choices they're both of the same quality now you introduce a third choice that is Pareto dominated which means it's worse in every way to one of the two choices people will pick the choice that's better than that third choice so for example if i have like like if if there's like girls trying because you know we do programming throw down there's constantly girls asking us for our numbers so if me and patrick are at a bar dude i just made all these nice things to you right now you're totally gonna lose it all if me if me and pat Patrick are at a bar. Dude, I just made all these nice things to you, right? So, like, now you're totally going to lose it all.
这三个选择质量大致相同，或者你甚至不知道它们的质量，或者不，抱歉，我弄错了。你有两个选择，它们质量相同。现在你引入了第三个选择，它是帕累托占优的，这意味着它在各个方面都比其中一个选择差。人们会选择那个比第三个选择更好的选择。例如，如果有女孩试图……因为我们在做编程，经常有女孩问我们要号码。所以如果我和 Patrick 在酒吧……伙计，我刚才对你说了这么多好话，你现在完全要搞砸了。如果我和 Patrick 在酒吧，
If me and Patrick are at a bar, and let's say, like, just if two of us were at a bar, we'd have an equal chance of getting picked up. If you introduce a slightly, like, ugly. I'm not condoning this conversation. Like, I don't even know if I want to let you go forward. No, no. If you introduce, like, a slightly uglier, like, slightly, like, I don't even know if I want to let you go forward. No, no. If you introduce a slightly uglier, slightly more disheveled version of Patrick,
伙计，我刚才对你说了这么多好话，对吧？所以，现在你完全要搞砸了。如果我和 Patrick 在酒吧，假设只有我们两个在酒吧，我们被搭讪的机会是相等的。如果你引入一个稍微……有点丑的……我不是在纵容这种对话。我甚至不知道我是否想让你继续说下去。不，不。如果你引入一个稍微丑一点、稍微邋遢一点的 Patrick 版本，
the chances of girls picking Patrick over me goes up dramatically. And even though Patrick hasn't changed. Yes. Oh, yeah, yeah. I've heard it before. And he actually... It's because it gives you an anchor.
女孩选择 Patrick 而不是我的机会会急剧上升。即使 Patrick 没有改变。是的，哦，是的，是的。我以前听过。他实际上……这是因为它给了你一个锚点。
You say, oh, at least I know this choice is better than that choice. Yeah, and it has something to do with the brain cannot, like, evaluate things in, like, high-dimensional spaces. But, like, it can see that, like, this thing is better than that. It's ranking. At least you can rank those.
你说，哦，至少我知道这个选择比那个选择好。是的，这与大脑无法在高维空间中评估事物有关。但是，它可以看出这个东西比那个好。这是排名。至少你可以对它们进行排名。
Like, it's very difficult to rank an apple versus an orange. Right. But if I put in another apple that's, you know, like, decayed, it's like, oh, at least I could take the good-looking apple. Yeah, exactly. It looks better than the decayed apple. Yeah. But I have no idea how to compare the apple and the orange. Right. thing with houses you just there's a really big problem with houses this is the whole comparable
比如，很难对苹果和橙子进行排名。没错。但如果我放进另一个腐烂的苹果，哦，至少我可以选那个好看的苹果。是的，完全正确。它看起来比那个腐烂的苹果好。但我不知道如何比较苹果和橙子。没错。房子也是一样，买房子时有一个很大的问题，这就是所谓的“可比性”
thing when you buy a house sorry we're getting off track but yeah so like when you go to buy a house it's very difficult to compare houses in different neighborhoods so people tend to really quickly focus in on one neighborhood and try to rank houses because then they can somehow rationalize the price. Even though that price has no, it's just whatever you'll pay for it, right? Like whenever the seller is willing to sell it to you. But it's very difficult for people to keep the search
当你买房子时。抱歉，我们跑题了，但是的，当你去买房子时，很难比较不同社区的房子。所以人们倾向于非常快地专注于一个社区，并尝试对房子进行排名，因为这样他们可以以某种方式合理化价格。即使那个价格没有任何依据，它只是你愿意支付的价格，对吧？就像卖家愿意卖给你的价格。但人们很难保持搜索
very large and open because it's very difficult to compare something that's a far commute, but very cheap and a very close commute, but very expensive. Like that comparison is very difficult. If you have to factor in like, oh, if I live here, the schools are bad. I'll have to pay for private school
非常广泛和开放，因为很难比较通勤很远但很便宜的房子和通勤很近但很贵的房子。这种比较非常困难。如果你必须考虑，哦，如果我住在这里，学校很差。我将不得不支付私立学校的费用，
and like factor in like the, like 20 or 30 different variables at each house. And like, you can't, your brain just cannot do that. And so, so yeah, what'll end up happening is you'll look at two houses. One will be better than the other in some like obvious way, like completely dominate
并考虑每栋房子 20 或 30 个不同的变量。你的大脑根本做不到这一点。所以，是的，最终会发生的是你会看两栋房子。其中一栋在某种明显的方面比另一栋好，完全压倒了
the other one and then your brain will make the mental leap as to say that house is better than average because it's better than this one something like that yeah yeah yeah it's all right wild we gotta move on we are very talkative tonight tool of the bi-week tool of the bi-week my tool the bi-week is pixen uh i don't know if i'm i think i mentioned this earlier how i was getting into doing art as a hobby like pixel art or maybe i just told you in private but but yeah so i've been doing pixel art i got one of those wake-on tablets and it's been pretty fun just drawing different things um and i've been using pixen and it's really a pretty cool tool it's only on mac which is a total bummer. I think there's a Windows equivalent software that you can find.
另一栋，然后你的大脑会产生心理飞跃，认为那栋房子比平均水平好，因为它比这一栋好，诸如此类。是的，是的，太疯狂了。我们得继续，我们今晚太健谈了。双周工具，双周工具。我的双周工具是 Pixen。我不知道我之前是否提到过我如何开始把艺术作为一种爱好，比如像素艺术，或者我只是私下告诉过你，但是的，所以我一直在做像素艺术。我买了一个 Wacom 平板电脑，画不同的东西很有趣。我一直在用 Pixen，它确实是一个非常酷的工具。它只在 Mac 上有，这真是太糟糕了。我想你可以找到 Windows 的等效软件。
So this open source software doesn't run on Linux? This is not open source. I know. Wait, that's... Dagger in the heart. I'm normally the one who's the horrible person for not... I'm a terrible person. Wait, I've got to go change my noun to something open source.
所以这个开源软件不能在 Linux 上运行？这不是开源的。我知道。等等，那是……心如刀割。我通常是那个因为不……而成为可怕的人。我是个糟糕的人。等等，我得去把我的名词改成开源的东西。
Let's capitalize. Let's capitalize. Go, go. So, yeah, people won't know which one of us is better unless you find an open source software because there's just too many dimensions otherwise. No, I'm presenting closed source as well, so now they can compare us.
让我们大写。让我们大写。走，走。所以，是的，人们不知道我们俩谁更好，除非你找到一个开源软件，因为否则维度太多了。不，我也在展示闭源软件，所以现在他们可以比较我们了。
Well, there's too many other things now. So, yeah, so Pixin does a lot of cool drawing. It will do, like, dithering and things like that. It'll let you look at the same object at multiple zoom levels simultaneously. It'll open 10 windows where the object is zoomed in, zoomed out, regular. And for doing pixel art, that's really important.
好吧，现在有太多其他东西了。所以，是的，Pixen 做很多很酷的绘图。它会做抖动之类的东西。它让你同时在多个缩放级别查看同一个对象。它会打开 10 个窗口，对象被放大、缩小、正常显示。对于做像素艺术来说，这非常重要。
Really cool app, highly recommended. Nice. My app is Downcast. Okay. Which is a fun play on words. So we are a podcast podcast and this is a podcast app so if you're not on ios you can stop listening for the next few few minutes but i happen to use an iphone and they updated to the new ios ios 6 and they moved podcast used to be part of like
非常酷的应用程序，强烈推荐。不错。我的应用程序是 Downcast。好的。这是一个有趣的双关语。所以我们是一个播客播客，这是一个播客应用程序，所以如果你不在 iOS 上，你可以在接下来的几分钟停止收听。但我碰巧使用 iPhone，他们更新到了新的 iOS 6，他们移动了播客，它曾经是像
where all the music and stuff was too it was just like kind of like a separate tab or separate screen but now they moved it up out into a separate app that app is horrible oh horrible that's the built-in like it basically like I almost thought like I listen to a lot of podcasts like every day on my commute I listen to podcasts I almost got podcast app wrong I mean looking at well so like just the all the like functionality that it used to have like i can't even begin to describe it like i need to i've like so blocked it from my memory i don't even remember what was so bad about it that i didn't like and this wasn't like oh i read online and like uh people are outraged no i'm outraged no this was like literally like i didn't
所有音乐和东西的一部分，它只是像一个单独的标签或单独的屏幕，但现在他们把它移到了一个单独的应用程序中。那个应用程序太糟糕了。哦，太糟糕了。那是内置的，就像……我基本上觉得……我每天通勤时听很多播客，我听播客，我差点把播客应用程序弄错了。我的意思是看着……好吧，它曾经拥有的所有功能，我甚至无法开始描述它。我需要……我已经把它从我的记忆中屏蔽了，我甚至不记得它有什么不好的地方，我不喜欢它。而且这不像是我在网上读到的，人们很愤怒，不，我很愤怒。不，这就像字面上……我
know it was coming i went to the normal app to pull up my podcast and it's like oh your podcasts are now in this other app and i'm like okay so you know you have to go download that app if you don't have it but i already did have it from earlier playing with it when it was optional feature um and it looks like i actually deleted it so i don't think you even have it so i can recall um so it's like oh yeah you know you need to go delete it or you need to go download it if you don't have it and so i download it and then it just like, Oh no, I remember like,
不知道它要来了，我去了正常的应用程序打开我的播客，它说，哦，你的播客现在在这个其他应用程序中。我说，好吧，所以你知道，如果你没有那个应用程序，你必须去下载它，但我之前玩它时已经有了，当时它是一个可选功能。而且看起来我实际上删除了它，所以我认为你甚至没有它，所以我可以回忆起来。所以它就像，哦，是的，你知道你需要去删除它，或者如果你没有它，你需要去下载它。所以我下载了它，然后它就像，哦不，我记得……
so one thing was if you start playing a podcast, right? So I'm playing a podcast. I've downloaded to the phone over USB cable or on wifi while I'm at the house. And so like I'm driving in the car, right? And all of a sudden, so that episode finishes and it starts playing the next episode.
所以有一件事是如果你开始播放播客，对吧？所以我正在播放播客。我通过 USB 线或在家里通过 Wi-Fi 下载到手机上。所以我在车里开车，对吧？突然间，那一集结束了，它开始播放下一集。
I'm like, I didn't know I had that one downloaded. Like, I guess I did. No, guess what was streaming over the internet the whole time i was driving to work the next episode guess what my battery was like when i got to work really low so that was a nice feature and i sure i probably could have figured out how to disable it and thankfully i don't have so i'm not still on the
我说，我不知道我下载了那一集。我想我下载了。不，猜猜我在开车去上班时一直在互联网上流式传输什么？下一集。猜猜我到公司时电池怎么样？非常低。所以那是一个不错的功能，我肯定可以弄清楚如何禁用它。谢天谢地，我没有……所以我不在
unlimited plan because oh no it's too long so it doesn't really matter to me and even then like the podcast wasn't huge so it wouldn't have been a big deal but the fact that like killed my battery just because of streaming yeah yeah and like i mean i guess it's a nice feature but i really would like confirmation that that was what was going to happen and just managing the subscriptions and it like uh i just really didn't like it i was having trouble figuring figuring out what things I had downloaded to the phone that I could just use. It downloaded the whole next episode? Like, it didn't try to stream? It didn't download it.
无限流量套餐上，因为哦不，它太长了，所以对我来说没关系。即使那样，播客也不大，所以不会是什么大问题。但它耗尽了我的电池，仅仅因为流式传输。是的，是的，我的意思是，我想这是一个不错的功能，但我真的希望确认那会发生，而且管理订阅，它……我真的不喜欢它。我很难弄清楚我下载到手机上可以使用的东西。它下载了整整下一集？它没有尝试流式传输？它没有下载它。
It streamed it, like, over time. But that's actually worse. Like, I would have rather to just download the whole thing at once. Oh, yeah, you're right. So now it's, like, keeps hitting it. Like, I don't know which penalty is worse. But I didn't end up having it downloaded when I got to work. Like, I only still had wherever I was in the stream.
它流式传输了它，随着时间的推移。但这实际上更糟。我宁愿直接下载整个东西。哦，是的，你是对的。所以现在它就像，一直在点击它。我不知道哪个惩罚更糟。但我到公司时并没有下载它。我仍然只在流中的任何位置。
Yeah, because if you had downloaded it all at home, then you would use Wi-Fi. Yeah, so that wouldn't have been a big deal if they had, like, downloaded the Wi-Fi. It's versus I'm in the car and it's just on 3G. Exactly. So anyways, Downcast is another app which does basically the same thing, only it seems much nicer. And maybe it's just because I got that one experience burned me so bad. I don't know.
是的，因为如果你在家里下载了它，那么你就会使用 Wi-Fi。是的，所以如果他们像下载 Wi-Fi 那样下载它，那不会是什么大问题。这与我在车里，它只是在 3G 上相比。完全正确。所以无论如何，Downcast 是另一个应用程序，它基本上做同样的事情，只是它看起来好多了。也许只是因为那次经历让我烧得太厉害了。我不知道。
But looking later on the Internet, it seems like a lot of people really don't like this app as well, this podcast app by Apple. So if you're looking for one, I recommend podcasts. We're on there. And a nice bonus feature is that when I look for, when I do a search for podcasts, I'm doing it right now to make sure this is still true, and I search programming, the
但后来在互联网上查看，似乎很多人也非常不喜欢这个应用程序，这个苹果的播客应用程序。所以如果你正在寻找一个，我推荐播客。我们在那里。一个不错的奖励功能是，当我寻找时，当我搜索播客时，我现在正在做，以确保这仍然是真的，我搜索编程，
very first result. Here we go. Check it out. I'm searching programming. Searching for podcasts. Whoa! Number one! Holy crap. Number one. It's amazing. Check it out. Searching programming. Searching for podcasts. Oh! Whoa! Number one! Holy crap. Number one! It's amazing. So number two is music for programming. We're number one!
第一个结果。我们开始吧。看看这个。我正在搜索编程。搜索播客。哇！第一名！天哪。第一名。太神奇了。看看这个。搜索编程。搜索播客。哦！哇！第一名！天哪。第一名！太神奇了。所以第二名是编程音乐。我们是第一名！
That's totally... Music for programming? You guys have nothing on us. So better than the iTunes store, which ranks programming, programming, because it says programming twice. I don't... Guys, if you listen to programming, programming people, I'm sorry. I don't know anything about you.
那完全是……编程音乐？你们没什么比得上我们的。所以比 iTunes 商店更好，它排名编程，编程，因为它说了两次编程。我不……伙计们，如果你听编程，编程的人，我很抱歉。我不知道关于你的任何事情。
No. I've never listened to your podcast. No, not at all. But you get ranked ahead of us, and I think it's because you just have programming twice in a row. So programming throwdown is number one. I have no idea what ranking it's using. It could be completely random.
不。我从来没有听过你的播客。不，一点也不。但你的排名在我们前面，我认为这是因为你只是连续两次有编程。所以编程 Throwdown 是第一名。我不知道它使用什么排名。它可能是完全随机的。
I don't care. It's amazing. Programming throwdown, which we'll, for now, forevermore call programming programming programming. No, we shouldn't be mean. Those guys might be really nice. No, I'm sure they have a great... Actually, the last episode they uploaded was in 2007. Oh oh all the more reason for us to be ahead of them so maybe it's just freshness although music for programming has a even more recent episode than
我不在乎。太神奇了。编程 Throwdown，我们现在，永远称之为编程编程编程。不，我们不应该刻薄。那些人可能真的很好。不，我相信他们有一个伟大的……其实，他们上传的最后一集是在 2007 年。哦，哦，更有理由让我们排在他们前面，所以也许只是新鲜度，尽管编程音乐有一集比
us so oh wow but anyways we're ranked really well in this which is just a nice side benefit but this one has things like it'll do the geofencing so like when i get home it'll automatically refresh my podcast list and start downloading anything new. Oh, dude. Like, once I get home. Dude, that's a brilliant – I've never heard of any app doing this. Really? I mean, it's such a good idea, right?
我们更近，所以哦哇，但无论如何，我们在这一点上排名很好，这只是一个不错的好处，但这个有像它会做地理围栏的东西，所以当我到家时，它会自动刷新我的播客列表并开始下载任何新的东西。哦，伙计。就像，一旦我到家。伙计，那是一个天才——我从来没听说过任何应用程序这样做。真的吗？我的意思是，这是一个好主意，对吧？
Okay, yeah. I guess I don't know. Oh, wait, no. So, like, the reminders from Apple does this. Why wouldn't it be geo, though? Why wouldn't it just wait for Wi-Fi or something? Well, so, for instance, like, if I'm on the road, like, I don't have access to charging. But once I'm home, like, it's actually fairly easy for me to charge.
好的，是的。我想我不知道。哦，等等，不。所以，比如，苹果的提醒事项这样做。为什么它不是地理位置呢？为什么它不只是等待 Wi-Fi 之类的？好吧，所以，例如，如果我在路上，我没有充电的机会。但一旦我到家，对我来说充电其实相当容易。
And you can set where it is. Like, I can set home. I can set work. So, at work, I have Wi-Fi as well, so I can do it at work. But I just don't want to do it in my car. And you can set it, like, leaving an area, which I don't exactly. But, like, arriving at an area. Wow.
你可以设置它在哪里。比如，我可以设置家。我可以设置工作。所以，在工作中，我也有 Wi-Fi，所以我可以在工作中做。但我只是不想在车里做。你可以设置它，比如离开一个区域，我不完全。但是，比如，到达一个区域。哇。
Between certain times, like, it can check daily how many episodes to keep. You know, what to do with new episodes if you already have old episodes it just seems very highly you can set it to sleep after a certain amount of time you can create playlists of podcasts you can tell it like i do want you to stream ones i don't have downloaded or never do that anyway it's much more configurable but the good side note is we're number one amazing amazing that's all thanks to you guys really i mean assuming that they're using you know voting and like stars we're gonna find out it's completely random and we're gonna be completely deflated but yes until then until then it's all thanks to you guys out there you know giving us good feedback making the show
在特定时间之间，比如，它可以每天检查要保留多少集。你知道，如果你已经有了旧剧集，该如何处理新剧集，这看起来非常高级，你可以设置它在一段时间后进入睡眠，你可以创建播客播放列表，你可以告诉它，比如我确实希望你流式传输我没有下载的剧集，或者永远不要那样做，无论如何，它的可配置性要高得多，但好的方面是，我们排名第一，太棒了，太棒了，这真的都要感谢你们，我的意思是，假设他们正在使用投票和星星，我们会发现这完全是随机的，我们会感到非常泄气，但是的，在那之前，在那之前，这都要感谢你们这些给予我们良好反馈、让节目变得
better i mean we take the feedback really seriously read all the email we read all the feedback on itunes yeah we're not always good about replying, but we do read it all. We're getting better, though. I actually have the programming throwdown at Gmail on my phone now. Oh, nice. So we have 65 ratings now. Yeah, amazing. That's pretty good. And I think this is only in the United States. I think it shows you localized results.
更好的听众，我的意思是，我们非常认真地对待反馈，阅读所有的电子邮件，我们阅读 iTunes 上的所有反馈，是的，我们回复得并不总是很好，但我们确实阅读了所有内容。不过我们正在改进。我现在手机上确实有 Gmail 的 Programming Throwdown。哦，不错。所以我们现在有 65 个评分了。是的，太棒了。这相当不错。而且我认为这仅在美国。我认为它向你显示本地化的结果。
Yeah, it says U.S. So I don't know if people in other countries want to look, but I know we had an email from a listener in Germany. Yeah, yeah. So I think we had one from brazil a couple couple weeks ago yeah so we've got listeners all over the place although you're saying beta earlier people know we're in the u.s right because this is beta and beta yeah yeah so is alpha still alpha yeah i think so i don't know you know what was that one word but thank you all. To interrupt your thinking of our listeners. Thank you, guys.
是的，它显示美国。所以我不知道其他国家的人是否想看，但我知道我们收到了一封来自德国听众的电子邮件。是的，是的。所以我想几周前我们收到了一封来自巴西的邮件，是的，所以我们在各地都有听众，尽管你刚才提到了测试版，人们知道我们在美国，对吧，因为这是测试版，测试版，是的，是的，那么阿尔法版还是阿尔法版吗，是的，我想是的，我不知道，你知道那个词是什么，但谢谢你们所有人。打断你们对我们听众的思考。谢谢你们，伙计们。
When I went to London, I noticed that I say process, and the guys in London say process. That was the big one that, you know, because we're all nerds. We're clearly saying process a lot more than beta. I guess because we are computer science nerds and not math nerds. Maybe. Anyway, 65 reviews, that's pretty good. There's a lot of well like, well-known podcasts
当我去伦敦时，我注意到我说 process（过程），而伦敦的伙计们说 process。这是一个很大的不同，你知道，因为我们都是书呆子。我们显然说 process 的次数比 beta 多得多。我想是因为我们是计算机科学书呆子，而不是数学书呆子。也许吧。总之，65 条评论，这相当不错。有很多知名的播客
that have, like, only, like, 65 reviews or 50 reviews. Yeah, totally, totally. They have the same as us. No, I mean, but, like, we're doing pretty good. This is good, man. Yeah, I mean. We haven't checked our download count recently, I don't think. Have you?
只有 65 条或 50 条评论。是的，完全正确，完全正确。他们和我们一样。不，我的意思是，我们做得相当不错。这很好，伙计。是的，我的意思是。我想我们最近没有检查我们的下载量。你检查过吗？
I haven't checked recently, but I can do that. But a lot of our, you know, more recent episodes have been based on user feedback. Like, someone suggested that we do that. Oh, that's true, yeah. Yeah, someone keeps suggesting we do like Ruby or JavaScript or query languages, et cetera, so databases. So I appreciate you guys' feedback.
我最近没有检查，但我可以这样做。但是我们的许多（你知道的）较新的剧集都是基于用户反馈的。比如，有人建议我们这样做。哦，那是真的，是的。是的，有人一直建议我们做 Ruby 或 JavaScript 或查询语言等等，也就是数据库。所以我很感谢你们的反馈。
Yep, and on that note about databases, we're on to the topic of the week, query languages. Yes, query. Query or query? Oh, man, I'm going to think about how I'm saying it. Query. Query. Query. Query or query Oh man I'm going to think About how I'm saying it Query Query Query
是的，关于数据库，我们进入本周的主题，查询语言。是的，查询（Query）。Query 还是 Query？哦，天哪，我得考虑一下我是怎么说的。Query。Query。Query。Query 还是 Query，哦，天哪，我得考虑一下我是怎么说的，Query，Query，Query。
Query Query eye for the straight Dude I I You're going to make me Like have to edit you Out of the whole podcast It's going to be
Query，Query，直男的眼睛，我，你这是要让我把你从整个播客中剪掉，这将会是
Patrick only this time Yeah We're going to have to Change the queen rating Oh I was going to mention That actually Because I was listening To another podcast
这次只有帕特里克，是的，我们得改变女王的评分，哦，我本来想提一下，因为我正在听另一个播客
And they were talking About this So a little behind the scenes What do they call it Inside baseball Okay So we do the whole show in one take yeah totally like we i like so i'd edit the show and we'd do one exception when our internet went out but yes okay yeah that's true
他们在谈论这个，所以一点幕后花絮，他们称之为“棒球内幕”，好吧，所以我们一次性录完整个节目，是的，完全是这样，比如我喜欢编辑节目，我们只有一次例外，就是我们的互联网断了，但是的，好吧，那是真的。
we've had one where internet went out but every other time we do it straight through once and i hardly ever delete anything like i think just once or twice like i've deleted a section where one of us like coughed or something yeah but yeah for the most part, we slap on the beginning part, the end part, listen to make sure good, and that's it. So, it's like, we do, like, this is totally, like, we don't edit to make it, like, us sound better. We're this terrible in real life. Like, we don't have to be edited to sound worse. We could come to your school and talk, and we'd be this bad. That's, like, we could do this in front like oh oh we'll
我们有一次互联网断了，但其他时候我们都是一次性录完的，我几乎从不删除任何东西，我想只有一两次，我删除了我们其中一个人咳嗽之类的部分，是的，但总的来说，我们把开头部分、结尾部分接上，听一遍确保没问题，就这样。所以，这就像，我们确实，这完全是，我们不会为了让我们听起来更好而进行编辑。我们在现实生活中就是这么糟糕。我们不需要被编辑得更糟。我们可以去你的学校演讲，我们也会这么糟糕。就像，我们可以在前面做这个，哦，哦，我们会
talk about that in a minute yeah all right so hidden fun stuff so query languages stay till the end everybody so this is cut cut to the bone the meat the meat of the situation what is the what is the one everybody knows about sequel sql that's right it's so people know about it so well they've turned the acronym into like a word like they've tried saying sql so on that when in c++ when i write c-o-u-t how do you say that c out okay that's how i say it as well but some people say count those people i know people who say cow i don't want to generalize like i don't want to sound okay what about what about but what about p-r-i-n-t-f print f okay this is the same as me so so so the people i know who say i in it's because they the people i know who say count it's because they they didn't grow up thinking of out as a word
一会儿再谈那个，好的，所以隐藏的有趣的东西，所以查询语言，大家留到最后，所以这是切入骨髓，切入情况的实质，每个人都知道的那个是什么，SQL，没错，人们对它太了解了，以至于他们把缩写变成了一个词，就像他们试着说 SQL，所以当在 C++ 中我写 c-o-u-t 时，你怎么说那个，C out，好的，我也是这么说的，但有些人说 count，那些人，我知道有人说 cow，我不想概括，我不想听起来，好吧，那 p-r-i-n-t-f 呢，print f，好的，这和我一样，所以那些我知道说 i-n 的人，是因为他们，我知道说 count 的人，是因为他们没有从小把 out 当作一个词来想
like they know it's a word now but like english isn't their first language and so they just look at the whole thing phonetically whereas we're trained because we knew English from the beginning. We're trained to see the out in the sea. But I kind of like people who that's not true. So I don't mean to generalize. There's nothing wrong if you say just these aren't actual real words. So you know like people were like English-speaking since birth who say cow. Yeah, and they're very defensive of it.
就像他们现在知道它是一个词，但英语不是他们的第一语言，所以他们只是从语音上看着整个东西，而我们受过训练，因为我们从一开始就懂英语。我们受过训练，能看到 C 里的 out。但我有点喜欢那些人，那不是真的。所以我不是要概括。如果你说这些不是真正的词，也没什么错。所以你知道，就像人们从出生起就说英语，却说 cow。是的，而且他们对此非常抵触。
Really? Yeah, like and sin instead of C-in. But, I mean, clearly, you know, so just to refresh people's memory, C-out is when you want to stream things out to the console. In C. So it's actually short for console out. That's why it's C-out.
真的吗？是的，就像用 sin 代替 C-in。但是，我的意思是，很明显，你知道，为了刷新人们的记忆，C-out 是当你想要将东西流式传输到控制台时。在 C 中。所以它实际上是 console out 的缩写。这就是为什么它是 C-out。
Oh, I didn't know that. I actually thought it was C because it's a programming language. This is C-out as in C++. But also it's a pair because it This is C out as in C++. But also it's a pair because it's always C out and C in. Yeah. So you see those right next to each other. Right. So, I mean, the C part is common.
哦，我不知道。我实际上以为它是 C，因为它是一种编程语言。这是 C-out，就像 C++ 一样。但它也是一对，因为它总是 C out 和 C in。是的。所以你看到它们紧挨在一起。对。所以，我的意思是，C 部分是通用的。
Yeah. You just blew my mind, dude. So you can go back to that guy who says cout and you can be like, listen, buddy. Yeah, that's what I'm going to do. I don't get beat up, dude. It's your director. Okay, anyways, back on the topic, SQL.
是的。你刚才让我大开眼界，伙计。所以你可以回到那个说 cout 的家伙那里，你可以说，听着，伙计。是的，我打算这么做。我不会被打的，伙计。这是你的导演。好吧，无论如何，回到主题，SQL。
And now we pronounce it SQL. JOHN MCCUTCHAN- Yeah. So SQL is used to query databases, primarily. So the canonical SQL is select star from and then the database name. So if I have a SQL database, which means a database that can be queried in SQL, actually, I guess there are some other...
现在我们把它读作 SQL。JOHN MCCUTCHAN- 是的。所以 SQL 主要用于查询数据库。所以规范的 SQL 是 select star from 然后是数据库名称。所以如果我有一个 SQL 数据库，这意味着一个可以用 SQL 查询的数据库，实际上，我想还有一些其他的……
Yeah, so, I mean, we should talk about that. But SQL is as a language, right? So, first as a caveat, we love caveats here. Totally. We don't condone this behavior, you know, whatever. We like caveats. It's like caviar, but cheaper. There's like four face palms.
是的，所以，我的意思是，我们应该谈谈那个。但 SQL 是一种语言，对吧？所以，首先作为一个警告，我们这里喜欢警告。完全正确。我们不宽恕这种行为，你知道，随便吧。我们喜欢警告。这就像鱼子酱，但更便宜。有四次捂脸。
So the language of SQL, or query languages in general, can be distinct from their data that's underneath. So sometimes a translation is done. You can write a query in SQL, but a translation is done to some native query when it's executed, or whatever. But SQL is just kind of like, it is very much like a programming translation is done to some native query when it's executed or whatever. But SQL is just kind of like, it is very much like a programming language in that it can
所以 SQL 的语言，或者一般的查询语言，可以与它们底下的数据区分开来。所以有时会进行翻译。你可以用 SQL 编写查询，但在执行时会翻译成某种原生查询，或者其他什么。但 SQL 只是有点像，它非常像一种编程语言，因为它
get compiled, it can get optimized, it can get, not in the same way, but in a way. And it is distinct from the data that's underneath. Yeah. So for example, I did some work in C-sharp a long time ago. So this might not even be true anymore. But C-sharp uses, we used TSQL, like the Microsoft Transact SQL, and there was this thing called a stored procedure.
可以被编译，可以被优化，可以被，不是以同样的方式，但以某种方式。它与底下的数据是不同的。是的。例如，我很久以前在 C# 中做过一些工作。所以这可能不再是真的了。但 C# 使用，我们使用 TSQL，比如微软的 Transact SQL，有一个东西叫存储过程。
And what this was is you wrote this SQL code, but then it compiled it down into something that was like at a very low level, like in some low level TSQL instructions that could be executed really quickly. So for example, if you wanted to get all the users in the database, you know, in pagination of 10 at a time. So, like, the whole, you know, sending that command over the wire, you know,
这就是你编写这段 SQL 代码，但随后它将其编译成某种非常低级的东西，比如一些可以非常快速执行的低级 TSQL 指令。例如，如果你想获取数据库中的所有用户，你知道，一次分页 10 个。所以，整个，你知道，通过网络发送该命令，你知道，
the text, and then, like, receiving it, you know, in the database and then processing it, that could take time. So this stored procedure was a way of doing all that compilation beforehand. Oh, and I actually didn't get good to my caveat before, but that we're not really talking about the backend system so much. We will, and how they relate. So the whole database administration is a very ripe field, and we are not, I don't know much about that at all.
文本，然后，比如，在数据库中接收它，然后处理它，那可能需要时间。所以这个存储过程是一种预先完成所有编译的方法。哦，我实际上在警告之前没有说好，但我们并没有真正谈论后端系统那么多。我们会谈论的，以及它们是如何关联的。所以整个数据库管理是一个非常成熟的领域，而我们，我对此一点也不了解。
Me neither. So querying, the SQL, the query part, I mean, I'm not great at it, but I understand the querying part. But the actual administration and schema creation, so schema being we talked before about things that define what the data is stored like. And so this is another, you know, the schema kind of says how are we storing the data. And then query is written against the schema. So you query the data that's stored in the way that the schema specifies.
我也不了解。所以查询，SQL，查询部分，我的意思是，我不擅长，但我理解查询部分。但实际的管理和模式创建，所以模式是我们之前谈到的定义数据存储方式的东西。所以这是另一个，你知道，模式有点说明我们是如何存储数据的。然后查询是针对模式编写的。所以你查询以模式指定的方式存储的数据。
Yeah. So we're not going to talk a lot about that stuff. Yeah, we won't get into B-trees or, like, how databases work. I mean, that stuff gets really ugly. So, yeah. But, yeah, so, like, the queries are written against language. And I think it's an interesting point. So kind of, like, when people go through learning about programming and not necessarily like at college, but like in an early stage, a lot of times your first thing is like you write very code that just kind of runs.
是的。所以我们不会谈论太多关于那些东西。是的，我们不会深入研究 B 树或数据库是如何工作的。我的意思是，那些东西变得非常丑陋。所以，是的。但是，是的，所以，查询是针对语言编写的。我认为这是一个有趣的观点。所以有点像，当人们学习编程时，不一定是在大学，而是在早期阶段，很多时候你的第一件事就是你编写非常简单的代码，它只是运行。
It doesn't store anything. And then you need to store something. Like, oh, I want to remember something or somebody chooses something and I want to remember that or I want to write some output. So you typically write to a file on disk or whatever, you know, and you just learn to read and write files. But then when you move up from that and you want to have multiple users and store lots of data, right, so you begin to look like, how am I going to do that? Well, you can write, like, structured data, like XML,
它不存储任何东西。然后你需要存储一些东西。比如，哦，我想记住一些东西，或者某人选择了什么，我想记住它，或者我想写一些输出。所以你通常会写入磁盘上的文件或其他什么，你知道，你只是学习读写文件。但当你从那里提升，想要拥有多个用户并存储大量数据时，对吧，所以你开始看起来，我该怎么做？好吧，你可以编写，比如，结构化数据，比如 XML，
and write that to the disk. But I think the first kind of thing people encounter these databases, like the first thing that people interact with that's not on their computer. Right. So you can, and we'll talk about it later, there are ways to run databases that are on your computer. But to be honest, if you're doing that, you don't need to know if it's on your computer or not. It doesn't matter.
并将其写入磁盘。但我认为人们遇到的第一种数据库，就像人们交互的第一件不在他们电脑上的东西。对。所以你可以，我们稍后会谈论它，有办法运行在你电脑上的数据库。但老实说，如果你这样做，你不需要知道它是否在你的电脑上。这没关系。
Right. But at least in my case, and I think in many cases, the first time you're doing something between computers, multiple systems being involved, is talking to a database. Yeah, definitely. Because a database can run wherever. And it can be serving 100 people at once. And invariably, you see people hit this wall. Like, they start off with just one text file with all their data. And then that becomes really slow.
对。但至少在我的情况下，我认为在许多情况下，你第一次在计算机之间做某事，涉及多个系统，就是与数据库对话。是的，绝对。因为数据库可以在任何地方运行。它可以同时为 100 个人服务。而且总是，你会看到人们撞上这堵墙。比如，他们开始时只有一个包含所有数据的文本文件。然后这变得非常慢。
You either have to read the whole file into memory or something. So then you do something like, oh, each row in the file will mean something. So I can go straight to a specific row. Or maybe I'll have a file for each user. And I'll let the directory structure work. But then what really kills you and where you really understand oh I need to get a database and SQL is when you run into needing secondary keys so in other words let's say I have like so say what a key is oh yeah so so you know data in a database
你要么必须把整个文件读入内存，要么其他什么。所以你做一些事情，比如，哦，文件中的每一行都意味着什么。所以我可以直接跳转到特定的行。或者也许我会为每个用户准备一个文件。我会让目录结构来工作。但真正让你痛苦的是，你真正理解“哦，我需要一个数据库和 SQL”的地方，是当你遇到需要二级键的时候，换句话说，假设我有，所以说键是什么，哦，是的，所以你知道数据库中的数据
is stored in some type of aggregate structure so in the case of like my sequel which is a database they store things in tables right and so a key would be the element that you almost that you typically want to use to look up a row in a database so it's usually unique so for example if I have a database of people's names and how much money they've spent on my company, I could use someone's name as the key, but there might be two John Smiths, right? And so that wouldn't work because they would collide. So I might just have every time a new user shows up, I give them a new number. So the first user gets one, the second user ever to the system gets two, so on and so forth.
存储在某种聚合结构中，所以以 MySQL 为例，它是一个数据库，它们把东西存储在表中，对吧，所以键将是你通常想要用来查找数据库中一行的元素，所以它通常是唯一的，例如，如果我有一个人名和他们在我的公司花了多少钱的数据库，我可以用某人的名字作为键，但可能有两个 John Smith，对吧？所以那行不通，因为它们会冲突。所以我可能只是每次有新用户出现时，给他们一个新号码。所以第一个用户得到 1，系统中的第二个用户得到 2，以此类推。
And that becomes my key. So as long as like Patrick's in the system I sort of keep around that oh Patrick is two one five four three and I can go and say get me the payments for two one four five three get me the you know expenditures get me like what emails I've sent them and you use this this key to sort of get all that data that's a primary key but then you'll end up running into situations where you need like get me everybody who's bought this product so I need to go through all the data and I need to look at like a column that isn't the key so I need to go
那成了我的键。只要帕特里克在系统中，我就保留那个，哦，帕特里克是 21543，我可以去说，给我 21453 的付款，给我，你知道，支出，给我，比如我发给他们的电子邮件，你使用这个键来获取所有这些数据，这是一个主键，但随后你会遇到需要“给我所有买了这件产品的人”的情况，所以我需要遍历所有数据，我需要查看一个不是键的列，所以我需要去
through all the users all the primary keys look up their information pull out the secondary key or pull out this other column, see if it's equal and then you know that would involve going through the entire database, right? So if you have secondary keys you could think of that as sort of little mini databases. It doesn't have all the data, it just has sort of pointers to the main database. So for example the primary key might be the user ID. And so I have this, this map, which maps like two, four or five, whatever to Patrick. But then I'll have the secondary key that maps like bought economics for dummies to Patrick and Jason and
遍历所有用户，所有主键，查找他们的信息，拉出二级键或拉出这一列，看看它是否相等，然后你知道，那将涉及遍历整个数据库，对吧？所以如果你有二级键，你可以把它们看作是某种小型的迷你数据库。它没有所有数据，它只是有指向主数据库的指针。例如，主键可能是用户 ID。所以我有了这个映射，它将 2、4、5 等映射到帕特里克。但我会有二级键，它将“买了《傻瓜经济学》”映射到帕特里克和杰森和
these other five people, right. And so as whenever you update one row, like if a new person, if Jim buys Economics for Dummies, now you have to update the row connected to that primary key where your real data is, and you have to update that secondary key. You have to add Jim to the list of the people who bought that. And if you have to do that, that's annoying. That's terrible. Yeah, and so doing all that is a nightmare. So that's what, yeah, exactly.
其他这五个人，对吧。所以每当你更新一行时，比如如果有一个新人，如果吉姆买了《傻瓜经济学》，现在你必须更新连接到那个主键的行，你的真实数据就在那里，而且你必须更新那个二级键。你必须把吉姆加到买了那个东西的人的名单里。如果你必须这样做，那很烦人。太糟糕了。是的，所以做所有这些是一场噩梦。所以这就是，是的，完全正确。
The database will do all that good stuff for you and uh you just write sql and so you almost got there but not quite but introduced the relational part of database so sql is a relational database and we've heard a lot of thing we're going to talk about a little bit about what relational database is and moving away from that but that wasn't originally originally the case it wasn't relational. Oh, really? Yeah. So before relational databases, they just weren't. They just were flat.
数据库会为你做所有这些好事，呃，你只需要写 SQL，所以你几乎到了那里，但还没有完全到，但介绍了数据库的关系部分，所以 SQL 是一个关系型数据库，我们听到了很多关于我们要谈论一点什么是关系型数据库以及远离它的东西，但那最初并不是那样的情况，它不是关系的。哦，真的吗？是的。所以在关系型数据库之前，它们只是不是。它们只是平面的。
So then we introduced relational databases. Oh, okay. Do you want to talk about what the feature of that is? No, you go for it. All right. My throat's sore. So, yeah. So we introduced the concept of relational databases. This is what we know today.
所以我们引入了关系型数据库。哦，好吧。你想谈谈它的特点是什么吗？不，你来吧。好的。我的喉咙痛。所以，是的。所以我们引入了关系型数据库的概念。这就是我们今天所知道的。
And it seems like, in hindsight, like, oh, this seems intuitive or whatever. But Jason introduced the notion of a key so a key can identify uniquely identify a row in your table right so you think of rows and columns so rows being different entities and columns you know attributes of that entity or there's various ways of talking about it and we're not experts we're probably not using the right words, but that's okay. So relational says, oh, okay, I have that key. So Jason talked about, let's call it an identifier, an ID.
事后看来，这似乎是直观的，或者其他什么。但杰森引入了键的概念，所以键可以唯一地标识你表中的一行，对吧，所以你想到行和列，所以行是不同的实体，列是该实体的属性，或者有各种谈论它的方式，我们不是专家，我们可能没有使用正确的词，但这没关系。所以关系型说，哦，好的，我有那个键。所以杰森谈到了，让我们称之为标识符，一个 ID。
So my user ID is whatever that number you said. And so that can identify a table that lists my name. But why do I also have to have the table that says what I bought there? Because I might have bought multiple things. And how do I, that gets confusing now because the database runs most efficiently if, you know, there is a key that identifies everything, like uniquely identifies each row so that, you know, it's very fast and efficient to look it up when you provide that key
所以我的用户 ID 是你说的那个数字。所以那可以标识一个列出我名字的表。但为什么我还要有那个说我买了什么的表呢？因为我可能买了很多东西。我该怎么做，这现在变得令人困惑，因为如果有一个键可以标识所有东西，比如唯一标识每一行，那么数据库运行效率最高，这样，你知道，当你提供那个键时，查找它非常快速和高效
because it knows exactly the one place where it is. Yeah, yeah. And so multiple things could be combined to form a key, but in the case where I bought multiple things you might have to use like a date but I don't it's not really convenient for me to look up things that Patrick has bought by date so I have his unique identifier I can look up his name oh that's Patrick okay now we'll look at the things he bought well I can list one thing there but when he buys a new one do I just overwrite
因为它确切地知道它在哪里。是的，是的。所以多个东西可以组合成一个键，但在我买了很多东西的情况下，你可能不得不使用日期，但我不想，我查找帕特里克买的东西按日期查找并不方便，所以我有了他的唯一标识符，我可以查找他的名字，哦，那是帕特里克，好的，现在我们看看他买的东西，好吧，我可以在那里列出一件东西，但当他买了一件新东西时，我只是覆盖
this and this is the problem before relational databases this becomes inefficient you end up with like a column that has to store a list of things in it. Right, or multiple rows. And then that's inefficient because it's essentially collisions in your map, if you think about it. So the relational database was introduced, and that was this table relates to this other table. So now I have the unique identifier that points to the entry that is names and addresses
这个，这就是关系型数据库之前的问题，这变得低效，你最终得到一个必须在其中存储列表的列。对，或者多行。然后这很低效，因为如果你仔细想想，它本质上是你的映射中的冲突。所以引入了关系型数据库，那就是这个表与另一个表相关联。所以现在我有了指向条目的唯一标识符，即姓名和地址
right because people only let's assume for simplicity's sake initially only have one name and address but then i have another one that is things that that user has bought right and then that's you know some other so it uses the same key user id but then maybe it has like user id and something else like just another id like purchase id or whatever and something else, like just another ID, like purchase ID or whatever, right? Something else. And then I can link those things together in what's called a, so that's a relationship. So I define the relationship, you know, like, oh, this thing relates to this thing in this way. Oh, that's too many things.
对，因为人们只，让我们为了简单起见，最初只有一个人名和地址，但我有另一个是该用户买的东西，对吧，然后那是，你知道，其他一些，所以它使用相同的键用户 ID，但也许它有，比如用户 ID 和其他东西，比如只是另一个 ID，比如购买 ID 或其他什么，对吧？其他东西。然后我可以把这些东西链接在一起，这就是所谓的，所以那是一种关系。所以我定义了关系，你知道，比如，哦，这个东西以这种方式与这个东西相关。哦，那东西太多了。
And I'm probably doing a terrible job of describing this, but that's okay. No, no, it's good. So they relate. And then the other concept that you get to immediately once you do that is joining data from one table to another. Right. So you have the secondary keys like JSON, you have the primary keys, you have what's called a foreign key. So like this key also references this other table. So it's a foreign key to that table.
我可能在描述这个方面做得非常糟糕，但这没关系。不，不，这很好。所以它们相关。然后你一旦这样做就会立即得到的另一个概念是连接一个表到另一个表的数据。对。所以你有像 JSON 那样的二级键，你有主键，你有所谓的外部键。所以这个键也引用了另一个表。所以它是那个表的外部键。
Ah, I see. You also have another thing that we haven't touched on now is you have indexes, indices. Right, which is how you do these efficient lookups. lookup yeah yeah which is all sort of things you do behind the scenes but in SQL you can actually if you're writing SQL to select from a particular column if that column is indexed it'll go much faster yes yeah yeah or if you're adding restrictions so like I know that I want only the column that has Jason's user a you're a like So I say where the user ID equals Jason's number. That's really fast if that is the key or at least in an index.
啊，我明白了。你还有另一个我们现在还没触及的东西，就是你有索引，索引。对，这就是你进行这些高效查找的方式。查找，是的，是的，这都是你在幕后做的事情，但在 SQL 中，如果你正在编写 SQL 以从特定列中选择，如果该列被索引，它会快得多，是的，是的，或者如果你正在添加限制，比如我知道我只想要有杰森用户的列，所以我说用户 ID 等于杰森的数字。如果那是键或者至少在索引中，那真的很快。
Yeah, and some of these systems are even clever enough where they'll analyze your SQL over time. And if you're making many calls to a column that isn't indexed, they'll index it for you. Or at least they'll ping you as a potential optimization of your database. So SQL can actually be used to sort of optimize your database if it's used often enough. So anyway, so it gets into joins. And so this is the thing that gets into the meat of SQL
是的，其中一些系统甚至足够聪明，它们会随着时间的推移分析你的 SQL。如果你多次调用一个没有被索引的列，它们会为你索引它。或者至少它们会提醒你作为数据库的潜在优化。所以 SQL 实际上可以用来优化你的数据库，如果它被使用得足够频繁的话。所以无论如何，它进入了连接。所以这就是进入 SQL 实质的东西
programming is doing these joins and then also sub-queries. So I want to run some query, get some results. And then I want to essentially query that query. So I restrict the data set to some set, and then I want to query that restricted set for further information. Yeah, one kind of interesting thing about SQL is SQL reads from tables, but it returns a table. So, for example, if you say select user ID and name from the users table,
编程就是做这些连接，还有子查询。所以我想要运行一些查询，得到一些结果。然后我想要本质上查询那个查询。所以我把数据集限制为某个集合，然后我想要查询那个受限集合以获取更多信息。是的，关于 SQL 的一个有趣的事情是 SQL 从表中读取，但它返回一个表。例如，如果你说从用户表中选择用户 ID 和名称，
what you will get out of that select is a table. And as Patrick said, that table sits somewhere in memory or in some kind of cache on disk or something. But you can then run these nested select statements where it's like, take this table that I just selected and select something else from it. So it's a pretty brilliant language. And then when you're doing join between multiple tables, you're essentially building up a new table that has added information in it.
你从那个选择中得到的是一个表。正如帕特里克所说，那个表位于内存中的某个地方，或者磁盘上的某种缓存中，或者其他什么。但你随后可以运行这些嵌套的 select 语句，就像，获取我刚刚选择的这个表，并从中选择其他东西。所以这是一种非常出色的语言。然后当你做多个表之间的连接时，你本质上是在构建一个添加了信息的新表。
So you're adding to the columns, essentially, of this returned table. Yep. And then that gets into, now we get into everybody has these complex queries that they build to do these really specific things that seem kind of like oh so frustrating why is it not working why is my query not returning what i what i need but if you had to do like what jason was describing in the beginning you'd be far worse off yeah totally yeah definitely so um you know there's so much crazy magic behind databases and um it's just it's a research topic actually like optimizing and how to run the back end,
所以你本质上是在增加这个返回表的列。是的。然后这就进入了，现在我们进入每个人都有他们构建的复杂查询来做这些非常具体的事情，看起来有点像，哦，太令人沮丧了，为什么它不起作用，为什么我的查询没有返回我所需要的，但如果你必须做杰森在开始时描述的那样，你会更糟。是的，完全正确，是的，绝对。所以，嗯，你知道，数据库背后有太多疯狂的魔法，而且，这实际上是一个研究课题，优化以及如何运行后端，
the database engine, the thing that is storing these datas and executing these queries and optimizing them. Yeah, and I mean, you know, no matter how little data you think you have, I mean, if you have hundreds of thousands or millions of records, you've got to be using a database.
数据库引擎，存储这些数据并执行这些查询并优化它们的东西。是的，我的意思是，你知道，无论你认为你有多少数据，我的意思是，如果你有成千上万或数百万条记录，你必须使用数据库。
I mean, if you want to have any kind of reasonable turnaround time you know it doesn't take a lot of data for you to get to the point where it's like oh i have to use a database and then you're running into using sql or something so we hear that term today big data so i mean from your example like big is relative i guess you start with like small data just in a file and it's bigger data like you don't have a larger data set and sql really can handle that but's bigger data, like I want to have a larger data set. And SQL really can handle that. But then you get to big data, which is the buzzword recently.
我的意思是，如果你想有任何合理的周转时间，你知道，你不需要很多数据就能达到“哦，我必须使用数据库”的地步，然后你就会运行使用 SQL 或其他东西，所以我们今天听到那个术语“大数据”，所以我的意思是，从你的例子来看，大是相对的，我想你从像文件中的小数据开始，它是更大的数据，就像你没有更大的数据集，而 SQL 确实可以处理它，但它是更大的数据，就像我想要一个更大的数据集。而 SQL 确实可以处理它。但随后你进入大数据，这是最近的流行语。
But that's even, so if your data just grows and grows and grows, eventually it takes longer and longer and longer to run these queries over all the columns and look for things. Then you can't index everything because the indexes would get too big. And so you have to go through every row looking for you know things that match that query and that then that's when we begin to introduce other things that are used oh um so like you know for running these and like we talk about the like hadoops like map reduces and you know oh we want to to do these things because that data is too big the traditional sql databases can't handle it it would just like it would just be
但这甚至，所以如果你的数据只是不断增长，最终运行这些查询遍历所有列并寻找东西需要越来越长的时间。然后你不能索引所有东西，因为索引会变得太大。所以你必须遍历每一行寻找，你知道，匹配该查询的东西，然后这就是我们开始引入其他东西的时候，哦，嗯，所以比如，你知道，为了运行这些，就像我们谈论像 Hadoop 的 MapReduce，你知道，哦，我们想要做这些事情，因为那些数据太大了，传统的 SQL 数据库处理不了，它只会，它只会是
really really hard yeah and a lot but a lot of time is spent like sql did scale way further than probably people thought it would yeah totally so you know so millions of people querying it per second you know millions of queries i guess that's a good man like queries per second i think that's a typical yeah you know parameter that they measure by so like you know just like how many people are creating the same time and that's another thing that's an advantage of not having a file, is that you and I can share this data out in the cloud. Yeah, no one's locked the file or anything.
真的真的很难，是的，而且很多时间都花在像 SQL 确实比人们想象的扩展得更远，是的，完全正确，所以你知道，所以数百万人在每秒查询它，你知道数百万次查询，我想那是一个好伙计，比如每秒查询次数，我想那是一个典型的，你知道，他们衡量的参数，所以就像，你知道，就像有多少人在同一时间创建，这是不拥有文件的另一个优势，就是你和我可以在云中共享这些数据。是的，没有人锁定文件或其他什么。
Yeah, we can, and then, we'll talk about it later, but, you know, that, then what happens when we want to write, not just read? Like, how do you handle that? Well, if you have only one file, it becomes problematic, but if we share a database, it handles that for us. Yeah, totally, totally. And the other thing is you might want to instrument your program.
是的，我们可以，然后，我们稍后会谈论它，但，你知道，那，然后当我们想要写入，而不仅仅是读取时会发生什么？比如，你怎么处理那个？好吧，如果你只有一个文件，它会变得有问题，但如果我们共享一个数据库，它会为我们处理那个。是的，完全正确，完全正确。另一件事是你可能想要检测你的程序。
So in other words, while your server is running, giving data to your users, providing data, you might want to write another program that sort of looks at the server every now and then and says, hey, what's going on, right? So SQL is a lot of these databases have like web interfaces where you can write SQL in like for example my SQL database has PHP my admin which is this PHP server that you run on the same machine as the database and then actually it doesn't even have to be on the same machine but you run this PHP server you
所以换句话说，当你的服务器正在运行，给你的用户提供数据，提供数据时，你可能想要编写另一个程序，偶尔看看服务器并说，嘿，发生了什么，对吧？所以 SQL 是许多这些数据库有像 Web 界面，你可以在其中编写 SQL，比如例如 MySQL 数据库有 PHP my admin，这是你在与数据库相同的机器上运行的 PHP 服务器，然后实际上它甚至不需要在同一台机器上，但你运行这个 PHP 服务器，你
go to this website that the server is running on and you can actually look at your data as it's changing so if this was on a file system like you'd have to like lock the file users wouldn't be able to do anything and then you look at some data and then you unlock it's just not practical right so SQL is not the only thing that people use our other things as well many of them yeah so there's some what is another one another one is sparkle so this is for semantic webs so this is a little bit different the idea here is um if you have a semantic web of information so the idea is you have a set of entities and then you have information on the connection between
去这个服务器正在运行的网站，你实际上可以在数据变化时查看它，所以如果这在一个文件系统上，就像你必须锁定文件，用户将无法做任何事情，然后你看一些数据，然后你解锁，这根本不实用，对吧？所以 SQL 不是人们使用的唯一东西，还有其他东西，其中许多，是的，所以有一些，什么是另一个，另一个是 Sparkle，所以这是为了语义网，所以这有点不同，这里的想法是，嗯，如果你有一个信息语义网，所以想法是你有一组实体，然后你有关于连接的信息
the entities so for example um let's say you had uh let's say you had all of Facebook's data and so each node was like a person and then the connections between them also information like these two people are in a relationship or married or friends or not friends or they used to be friends and now they're not friends that could mean something right so whenever you have like this what's called semantic web but you have like information that's sort of stored in this way Um sparkle is sort of a query language. It's really good for dealing with this So there's plenty of other types of query languages
实体，所以例如，嗯，假设你有所有 Facebook 的数据，所以每个节点就像一个人，然后它们之间的连接也是信息，比如这两个人处于恋爱关系或结婚或朋友或不是朋友或他们曾经是朋友现在不是朋友，那可能意味着什么，对吧？所以每当你像这样有所谓的语义网，但你有像以这种方式存储的信息，嗯，Sparkle 是一种查询语言。它非常擅长处理这个，所以还有很多其他类型的查询语言
And there's other things that are different like each each kind of database engine tends to have like a slightly different version of SQL Yeah, that's true certain commands that you think are part of language But aren't and are custom and how to do these, you know, the management stuff can be very different. Yeah, even like sometimes getting the current time. Like you might want to do just programmatic things which aren't really related to your database. Like you might want to say, for example, get me all the users in the past month.
还有其他不同的地方，比如每种数据库引擎往往都有略微不同的 SQL 版本。是的，这是真的。有些你认为属于该语言的命令，实际上并不是，而是自定义的。而且如何进行这些管理工作可能会有很大不同。是的，甚至有时获取当前时间也是如此。你可能只想做一些与数据库无关的程序化操作。比如，你可能想说，获取过去一个月的所有用户。
Well, you have to know what 30 days or what a month from from today well you need to know what today is yeah concept of it so a lot of those functions like either the names are a little different or you've tried to standardize it and it's a lot better now than it was you know a decade ago but but yeah there's still all sorts of nuances there so breezing through some of the rest of our traditional structure of language you know I covered it yeah we talked about interfacing from multiple systems. Transactional, I alluded to this
好吧，你必须知道 30 天或从今天起一个月是什么，你需要知道今天是什么。是的，这个概念。所以很多这样的函数，要么名字有点不同，要么你试图标准化它，现在比十年前好多了，但确实仍然存在各种细微差别。所以，快速浏览一下我们语言传统结构的其他部分，你知道，我讲过了。是的，我们讨论了与多个系统的接口。事务处理，我提到了这一点，
and didn't exactly talk about, but if Jason and I are both trying to write data, or Jason's trying to write and I'm trying to read, how is that handled? And that's a very complicated thing. Yeah, sorry, but it's being able to roll back. So the idea is like, if me and Patrick both, let's say there's one product left on Amazon's shelf.
但没有确切地谈论它。但是，如果我和 Jason 都试图写入数据，或者 Jason 试图写入而我试图读取，这是如何处理的？这是一个非常复杂的问题。是的，抱歉，但它是能够回滚。所以这个想法是，如果我和 Patrick 都，假设亚马逊货架上只剩下一个产品了。
Like, Amazon's selling economics for dum's say there's one product left at on Amazon's shelf like there's the Amazon selling economics for dummies and there's only one left and we both go to buy it at the same time so it uh it starts processing both of our transactions and then it charges Patrick's credit card and like I'm halfway through the transaction and so the problem is multiple queries need to be bundled together in this transaction right so it's not just one query that each of us are running. And it's just a race condition and one of us will get to it first. I mean, that is a problem.
就像，亚马逊在卖《傻瓜经济学》，假设亚马逊货架上只剩下一个产品了，我们俩同时去买它，所以它开始处理我们两个人的交易，然后它扣了 Patrick 的信用卡，而我的交易才进行到一半。所以问题在于多个查询需要捆绑在这个事务中，对吧？所以不仅仅是我们每个人运行的一个查询。这只是一个竞争条件，我们中总有一个会先抢到。我的意思是，这是一个问题。
But even the worst problem is we need to do multiple queries. I need to query your credit card. Then I need to write that I charged your credit card and tell something else to go charge your credit card. Then I need to go to the product once I've done that and deduct the amount by one or vice versa. But whatever, right? Like I need to do this set of steps. and we both need to execute that set of steps. But we need some way of, like you said, rolling back so that if one of us can't fully complete it, then, you know, we undo everything that happened, like all the other rights that happened during that need to get undone. Yeah,
但更糟糕的问题是我们需要执行多个查询。我需要查询你的信用卡。然后我需要写入我已经扣了你的信用卡，并告诉其他东西去扣你的信用卡。然后我需要在那之后去处理产品，并将数量减一，或者反之亦然。但无论如何，对吧？我需要执行这一系列步骤。我们俩都需要执行那一系列步骤。但我们需要某种方式，就像你说的，回滚，这样如果我们中有一个人不能完全完成它，那么，你知道，我们撤销发生的一切，就像在那个过程中发生的所有其他写入都需要被撤销一样。是的，
exactly. You need to go back to like none of them worked. It's all or nothing. And that's what a transaction is. Totally. Yeah. And it's very needed, very needed. And it has to, like you need to go back to, like, none of them worked. It's all or nothing. And that's what a transaction is. Totally, yeah. And it's very needed, very needed. And it has to, like, you have to know it's right. Yeah, I mean, imagine how terrible this would be. I mean, like, you would end up with, your credit card would get charged, right, as something came out of stock. You know, I mean, like, this could be just a complete disaster if it wasn't implemented right. And we didn't talk about it yet, but the ACID transactions.
没错。你需要回到像什么都没发生过的状态。要么全做，要么全不做。这就是事务。完全正确。是的。这是非常必要的，非常必要。而且它必须，就像你需要回到，就像什么都没发生过的状态。要么全做，要么全不做。这就是事务。完全正确，是的。这是非常必要的，非常必要。而且它必须，你必须知道它是正确的。是的，我的意思是，想象一下如果这很糟糕会怎样。我的意思是，你会最终导致，你的信用卡被扣了，对吧，但东西却缺货了。你知道，我的意思是，如果实现不当，这可能是一场彻底的灾难。我们还没谈到它，但 ACID 事务。
Oh, yeah. So, you know, this is a whole thing that is very popular to be talked about, and especially what we're going to talk about now, about the no SQL movement. So SQL, when you try to go too far in one parameter, try to apply it to every use case, which is kind of what happened. It was the tool, right? And, you know, I'd say maybe early to mid-2000s, right? Like that was everything's database.
哦，是的。所以，你知道，这是一个非常热门的话题，尤其是我们现在要谈论的关于 NoSQL 运动的话题。所以 SQL，当你试图在一个参数上走得太远，试图将其应用于每一个用例时，这正是发生的事情。它是当时的工具，对吧？而且，你知道，我想说可能是在 2000 年代初到中期，对吧？那时候一切都是数据库。
Even before, people were using database. But around that time, we started to run into problems where people were kind of using it, and maybe it wasn't the best tool. And part of that is that a lot of these servers strive for ACID compliance, which is atomicity, which we talked about being able to execute one instance in time, all those things, and it all works and nothing works.
甚至在此之前，人们就在使用数据库。但在那个时候，我们开始遇到一些问题，人们在使用它，但它可能不是最好的工具。部分原因是许多这些服务器追求 ACID 合规性，即原子性，我们谈到过能够在一个时间实例中执行，所有这些事情，要么全部成功，要么全部失败。
I think I'm getting it right. Consistency, so that things return the same for all of us. We don't get mixed results. And then that gets the problem when you have sharding and stuff. One server can't handle everybody, so I have to split it up. Isolation and durability. Durability has to do, I to do with surviving across reboots, right? So if you get randomly rebooted,
我想我理解得对。一致性，就是为了确保对我们所有人来说，返回的结果都是一样的。我们不会得到混乱的结果。然后当你进行分片等操作时，问题就来了。一台服务器无法处理所有人，所以我必须把它拆分。隔离性和持久性。持久性与重启后数据是否存续有关，对吧？所以如果你随机重启，
you know that you'll come back at the same time. Isolation. I'm not sure on that one. I'm not good. Actually, I don't know either isolation. Oh, here you go. There's a little article on it. Ensures that the concurrent execution of transactions. Oh, I i see so isolation means that
你知道你回来时数据还在。隔离性。我不确定这个。我不擅长。其实我也不知道隔离性。哦，给你。这里有一篇关于它的小文章。确保事务的并发执行。哦，我明白了，所以隔离性意味着
if there's like let's say there's i'm trying to buy a book and patrick's trying to buy a book and let's say there really are two in stock let's not worry about the crazy corner case the idea is if i buy and patrick buys or he buys first or we both buy at the same time, the end result should be the same. Like, it shouldn't be such that I buy the book. I mean, you can imagine this going wrong, right? Let's say there's two books, and let's say there's two in stock, and the code says take the number in stock and then subtract one and then set that to the new number. Well, if we both hit it at the same time, we'll both see two,
如果，比方说，我正在尝试买一本书，帕特里克也在尝试买一本书，假设库存里确实有两本，我们先别担心那些极端的特殊情况，核心思想是，如果我买，帕特里克也买，或者他先买，或者我们同时买，最终结果应该是一样的。比如，不应该出现我买到了书这种情况。我的意思是，你可以想象这会出错，对吧？假设有两本书，库存里有两本，代码逻辑是读取库存数量，然后减一，再将结果设为新数量。好吧，如果我们同时操作，我们都会看到库存是二，
we'll both subtract one, and then we'll both store one in the same time, we'll both see two. We'll both subtract one. And then we'll both store one in the database. And we really should have been zero. Yeah. So this acid thing is very useful. And many systems really need this. Yeah. But if you can do without one of these, you can begin to design something that's slightly different.
我们都会减一，然后我们都会同时存入一。我们都会看到二。我们都会减一。然后我们都会把一存入数据库。但实际上应该变成零才对。是的。所以这个 ACID 东西非常有用。许多系统确实需要它。是的。但如果你能舍弃其中一项，你就可以开始设计一些稍微不同的东西。
It's not exactly the same as what you were used to. Yeah. But, like, consistency is a big one. So consistency is, like we talked about, if you have multiple things running, I can write to one, and consistency says if I write to instance zero, instance three, when Jason tries to read from it
它和你习惯的并不完全一样。是的。但是，一致性是一个大问题。所以一致性就像我们讨论的那样，如果你有多个运行中的实例，我可以写入其中一个，而一致性要求如果我写入实例零，当杰森尝试从实例三读取时，
right after I write, also reflects the same thing. But that's pretty hard to do. So it doesn't always have to be true. Like, look at Twitter, for example. Right. So you get the notion of eventual consistency. Yeah. So it doesn't matter in Twitter if Jason tweets.
在我写入之后，它也应该反映出同样的内容。但这很难做到。所以它不一定总是成立。比如，看看 Twitter。对。所以你得到了最终一致性的概念。是的。所以在 Twitter 上，杰森发推文并不重要。
I don't mean to overstep that. No, no. Jason tweets, right? It doesn't matter if I go to check and I don't see Jason's tweet. It's the same millisecond he tweets. But I do want to see it within five seconds. Yep. But five seconds is a lot longer than zero.
我不是要越界。不，不。杰森发推文，对吧？如果我去查看时没看到杰森的推文，这没关系。不是在他发推文的同一毫秒内看到。但我确实希望在五秒内看到它。是的。但五秒比零秒长得多。
Yep. Totally. So if I get to eventual eventual consistency or maybe you don't even need consistency you know if it's a game or something maybe if you don't get it right away or it doesn't really matter it's not a big deal possibly it so if you can begin to start to violate some of these rules or you can do without transactions or without you without the durability that, you know, like again, like if I'm running a game server, maybe some parts of it, like all the people currently in the world,
是的。完全正确。所以如果我达到最终一致性，或者也许你根本不需要一致性，你知道，如果它是一个游戏之类的，也许如果你没有立即得到它，或者它真的没关系，那也不是什么大不了的事。可能吧。所以如果你能开始违反其中一些规则，或者你可以不需要事务，或者不需要持久性，你知道，就像我说的，如果我运行一个游戏服务器，也许其中的某些部分，比如当前世界里的所有人，
I don't need that to be durable. If it crashes and comes back out, everybody just starts back at their home base. Or if you're running like a chess server where you're hosting a bunch of chess games and the server dies and as a result of the server dying, all the people playing their games are lost. The reality is they'll just start new games, right?
我不需要它具有持久性。如果它崩溃了又恢复，每个人只是从他们的大本营重新开始。或者如果你运行一个像国际象棋服务器这样的东西，你托管了一堆棋局，服务器挂了，结果导致所有正在玩游戏的人都断开了。现实情况是，他们只会开始新的游戏，对吧？
It's not going to be the end of the world. But you would want to make, but you might have different needs. So like the player's rank, that might want to be durable. And you might want to use an SQL database for that. But then for just hosting the games, maybe it's really expensive to do all of those transactions against a database. So you might want to use something else. And these are the kinds of things that people began to deal with.
这不会是世界末日。但你确实会有不同的需求。所以，比如玩家的排名，那可能需要持久化。你可能想为此使用 SQL 数据库。但对于仅仅托管游戏而言，对数据库进行所有这些事务处理可能成本太高了。所以你可能想用别的东西。这些就是人们开始处理的问题。
And out came some of these things. Out came the NoSQL. Yeah. So the NoSQL movement is kind of a, what do you call it, like a misnomer? Like it's not exactly. It has nothing to do. It's like counterculture. Yeah.
于是就出现了这些东西。NoSQL 出现了。是的。所以 NoSQL 运动有点像，怎么说呢，用词不当？因为它并不完全是。它和它没关系。它就像反主流文化。是的。
It's one of those terms that doesn't make a whole lot of sense. But what it's getting at is that in NoSQL, instead of having these relationships defined and doing these expensive joins and indices, it's really geared to doing point lookups. So I just need to look up some bit of data. Like I want to look up this specific information about JSON, and I want to just store, kind of going back to what you talked about, like a whole complex thing, maybe some JSON or maybe some XML,
这是一个不太有意义的术语。但它的核心在于，在 NoSQL 中，不再定义这些关系，也不再进行昂贵的连接和索引，它真正针对的是点查询。所以我只需要查找某一点数据。比如我想查找关于 JSON 的特定信息，我想存储，回到你刚才谈到的，像一个完整的复杂事物，也许是一些 JSON 或 XML，
you know, something that's very structured. And I want to store all of that in one place. And I just want to pull it, look it up, and then I'll do some sort of analysis. And so, oh, I guess I'm skipping ahead. But running queries on that kind of thing is something slightly different. So if you're running on, let's say, Hadoop,
你知道，结构非常清晰的东西。我想把所有这些都存在一个地方。我只想提取它，查找它，然后我会做某种分析。所以，哦，我想我跳得太快了。但在那种东西上运行查询是稍微不同的事情。所以如果你在运行，比方说 Hadoop，
you're going to run, let's say you're going to run across analysis, everything, every row in the database. Let's say you have, so there's like an object store database. And what this does is this stores like an entire, as Patrick said, entire JSON or XML string. And you can think of it as sort of key value pairs. So there still is a primary key somewhere, like there's a user ID or something like that. And then the value is just this huge chunk of data. And the idea here is, you know, with SQL, it's really hard to do consistency across machines.
你要运行，比方说你要对所有东西进行分析，数据库中的每一行。比方说你有，所以有一个对象存储数据库。它的作用是存储整个，正如帕特里克所说，整个 JSON 或 XML 字符串。你可以把它看作是键值对。所以某处仍然有一个主键，比如有一个用户 ID 之类的。然后值就是这一大块数据。这里的想法是，你知道，使用 SQL，跨机器实现一致性真的很难。
I mean, you have to, like, take all your transactions, broadcast them. It's the N squared problem, right? Like, if you have five machines, every transaction, you know, that hits a machine then has to get spread to all the other five machines, right? So a different way of doing it would be oh let's have each of the machines just store a different amount of data like each of the machines store some part of the database and then I can query all five of them which you know that part is more expensive but the idea is I could have like a thousand machines or ten thousand machines they all are just storing bits and pieces of this
我的意思是，你必须，比如，获取你所有的事务，广播它们。这是 N 平方问题，对吧？比如，如果你有五台机器，每一个事务，你知道，击中一台机器，然后就必须传播到其他五台机器，对吧？所以一种不同的做法是，哦，让我们让每台机器只存储不同数量的数据，比如每台机器存储数据库的一部分，然后我可以查询所有五台机器，你知道，那部分更昂贵，但想法是我可以有一千台机器或一万台机器，它们都只是存储这些
database and even though it's more expensive to do this whole query, you know, asking 10,000 machines to do something is always going to be way faster than having five, right? Wow. You hope it's way faster. Well, I mean, yeah. I mean, in terms of this database stuff, yeah. But I mean, especially, like we were talking about, for the point where you need to read every row.
数据库的碎片，即使这样做整个查询更昂贵，你知道，要求 10,000 台机器做某事总是比只有五台要快得多，对吧？哇。你希望它快得多。好吧，我的意思是，是的。我的意思是，就这些数据库东西而言，是的。但我的意思是，特别是，就像我们谈到的，在你需要读取每一行的时候。
Right. And then you're going to do something, some manipulation of everything. SQL is not exactly, I mean, it can do that, I guess. I wouldn't say it's not meant for it. I mean, but that's not really the purpose. Right. So if I can store it somehow else, or if I'm making updates and I only need to just update
对。然后你要做某事，对所有东西进行某种操作。SQL 并不完全是，我的意思是，我想它可以做到。我不会说它不是为此设计的。我的意思是，但这并不是真正的目的。对。所以如果我可以以其他方式存储它，或者如果我正在进行更新，而我只需要更新
one specific thing, you know, and then when I read it, it's going to be in this manner. Or when I read it, I'm going to go pull the very specific row I need and it's got everything I need to it. Yep. Then in some ways it's overkill to use SQL. And you're sacrificing stuff by doing that. Yeah, totally, totally. And so there are languages written with this in mind.
某一个特定的东西，你知道，然后当我读取它时，它会以这种方式呈现。或者当我读取它时，我会去提取我需要的非常具体的行，它包含了所有我需要的东西。是的。那么在某些方面，使用 SQL 是杀鸡用牛刀。而且你这样做会牺牲一些东西。是的，完全，完全。所以有一些考虑到这一点的语言。
So you have a NoSQL database or even like you're running in Hadoop and something and then there are languages written to help you write those queries so you don't have to necessarily write Java code that has to run at each stage of the pipeline. You can write this query, and it'll generate the Java code for you. Yeah, and I mean, a lot of these people, they're not dummies. They know that a lot of the people who work with databases are used to SQL. And so they made theirs in sort of the form of SQL.
所以你有一个 NoSQL 数据库，或者甚至像你在 Hadoop 中运行某些东西，然后有一些语言编写出来帮助你编写这些查询，这样你就不必一定要编写必须在管道的每个阶段运行的 Java 代码。你可以编写这个查询，它会为你生成 Java 代码。是的，而且我的意思是，很多人，他们不是傻瓜。他们知道很多使用数据库的人习惯于 SQL。所以他们以 SQL 的形式制作了他们的东西。
So one is HiveQL, and that's part of the Apache Hive project. And so the idea is it'll go through a Hadoop database, or rather not a Hadoop. Hadoop is sort of like a clustering platform. It'll go over a Hive database. So that's like the file system, like the data storage layer. Yeah, exactly. It'll go through a Hive database, and it will, you know you know do so you could say things like select all of the documents where there is a you know in the JSON there's a name key and that name keys equal to Patrick or something like that and so it feels a lot like SQL but it's querying a completely different data structure on the back end it is not really I mean those are really meant for a real-time though like you're not serving something on a website without something batch processing.
所以一个是 HiveQL，它是 Apache Hive 项目的一部分。所以想法是它会通过一个 Hadoop 数据库，或者更确切地说不是 Hadoop。Hadoop 就像一个集群平台。它会通过一个 Hive 数据库。所以那就像文件系统，就像数据存储层。是的，完全正确。它会通过一个 Hive 数据库，它会，你知道，你知道做，所以你可以说像选择所有文档，其中有一个，你知道在 JSON 中有一个 name 键，那个 name 键等于 Patrick 之类的，所以它感觉很像 SQL，但它在后端查询一个完全不同的数据结构，它并不是真的，我的意思是那些并不是真的意味着实时，虽然你不会在没有批处理的情况下在网站上提供某些东西。
Like, I wonder about some report or analysis. And it's actually somewhat common for people to do a little bit of both. Like, I've heard of cases where people have an SQL database up front, which has a lot of the indices and the support for, like, pulling individual records. But then they end up piping it out to some like hadoop based system or some cluster for doing like the heavy lifting like look at everybody and calculate the average amount spent and all these other statistics standard deviation and things like that so yeah because you don't want to make your users suffer when you're trying to run some report yeah exactly that'd be bad yeah it used to be where you had two copies of your database you had the one you know that was latent
比如，我想知道一些报告或分析。而且人们同时做这两件事实际上很常见。比如，我听说过一些案例，人们在前端有一个 SQL 数据库，它有很多索引和支持，比如提取单个记录。但随后他们最终将其管道传输到某个基于 Hadoop 的系统或某个集群，用于做繁重的工作，比如查看每个人并计算平均花费以及所有这些其他统计数据、标准差之类的事情，所以是的，因为你不想在尝试运行某些报告时让你的用户受苦，是的，完全正确，那会很糟糕，是的，过去你有两份数据库副本，你有一份，你知道，那是延迟的
that was for doing your analysis. But as Patrick mentioned, SQL is not really designed for that. It's designed for serving. So if you're going to have two copies, it makes more sense for your second copy to be NoSQL. Yep, and so there are other tools related to all of this. So we talked about SQLite before.
那是为了做你的分析。但正如帕特里克提到的，SQL 并不是真正为此设计的。它是为服务设计的。所以如果你要有两个副本，你的第二个副本是 NoSQL 更有意义。是的，所以还有其他与所有这些相关的工具。所以我们之前谈到了 SQLite。
It's a tool of the week. So this is one that's an SQL database that runs locally and does write to a file on the back end that tries to make it more efficient up front. And there's MySQL, Postgres SQL. What is it? Oracle bought MySQL, but they have another SQL as well. Yeah, Oracle also
它是本周工具。所以这是一个在本地运行的 SQL 数据库，并确实写入后端的一个文件，试图使其在前端更高效。还有 MySQL，Postgres SQL。它是什么？Oracle 收购了 MySQL，但他们也有另一个 SQL。是的，Oracle 也
has Berkeley DB. Okay. They own that. Microsoft has some... Kind of like SQL Lite. SQL Server. Yeah, yeah. So there's, I mean, there's all sorts of tools. And there's, I mean, there's all sorts of tools. And there's tools for optimizing, running stuff in memory, making, you know, caching of queries, this kind of thing. Yeah, SQL Lite is a good one to sort of start with
有 Berkeley DB。好的。他们拥有那个。微软有一些……有点像 SQL Lite。SQL Server。是的，是的。所以有，我的意思是，有各种各样的工具。而且有，我的意思是，有各种各样的工具。而且有用于优化、在内存中运行东西、制作，你知道，查询缓存，这类事情的工具。是的，SQL Lite 是一个很好的开始
because you can always just delete the file and your database is gone. You don't have, like, some service running in the background. Like, you don't have to know SQL to, like, clean the database. And it's also easy to switch over from executing it against your local one to a remote one. So you're not wasting a lot of time. JOHN MCCUTCHAN- Yeah. DAN GALPIN- And pretty much everywhere on the web
因为你总是可以删除文件，你的数据库就没了。你没有，比如，在后台运行的某种服务。比如，你不需要知道 SQL 来，比如，清理数据库。而且从针对本地数据库执行切换到远程数据库也很容易。所以你不会浪费很多时间。JOHN MCCUTCHAN- 是的。DAN GALPIN- 几乎网络上的任何地方
uses a database in some manner. But I mean, even things like WordPress, all the articles that when you display on the back end, now there's some optimization that goes on, I'm sure. But all of those articles that text is stored as some blob of text in a row in a database somewhere. And when you go to the web page, in theory, it's querying that database and getting the stories by date and showing them to you on the front page.
都以某种方式使用数据库。但我的意思是，甚至像 WordPress 这样的东西，当你显示在后端时，所有的文章，现在有一些优化在进行，我肯定。但所有那些文章，文本被存储为某处数据库中一行里的文本块。当你去网页时，理论上，它正在查询那个数据库并按日期获取故事，并在首页上显示给你。
When you go to the next page, it's saying, get me the next three articles and showing you those. And in fact, like Wikipedia, you know, DBia is that is that what it's called no media wiki sorry media wiki which what which is what wikipedia is based on is um that software uses sql and you can actually download the sql file for all of wikipedia it's like this gigantic for trivopedia yeah and so so for people who don't know, SQL, you can select things from the database, which we talked about. You can also insert, update, and delete items from the database. So you can actually think of storing things in SQL code. Like if you had SQL code that, you know, created a database and then inserted
当你去下一页时，它说，给我接下来的三篇文章并显示给你。事实上，像维基百科，你知道，DBia 是那个，那是它叫什么，不，MediaWiki，抱歉，MediaWiki，也就是维基百科的基础，是，嗯，那个软件使用 SQL，你实际上可以下载所有维基百科的 SQL 文件，它就像这个巨大的，为了 trivopedia，是的，所以对于不知道的人，SQL，你可以从数据库中选择东西，我们谈到了。你也可以插入、更新和删除数据库中的项目。所以你实际上可以考虑用 SQL 代码存储东西。比如如果你有 SQL 代码，你知道，创建了一个数据库，然后插入
Patrick, you know, user ID, blah, blah, blah, Patrick, and then inserted all the things Patrick bought, that source code really has data in it. And that is the data. So a lot of these programs like MySQL, when you go to like dump the database or back up the database you get a gigantic block of code which is really just instructions for recreating the database from scratch and so wikipedia does this frequently and you can download like the biggest source file you'll ever see in your life like a 30 gigabyte source file which has all of the data i'll pass yeah all right well i think that's pretty much it. Oh, okay.
Patrick，你知道，用户 ID，等等，Patrick，然后插入了 Patrick 购买的所有东西，那个源代码确实有数据在里面。而那就是数据。所以很多这些程序，像 MySQL，当你去，比如转储数据库或备份数据库时，你会得到一大块代码，这实际上只是从头开始重新创建数据库的指令，所以维基百科经常这样做，你可以下载你一生中见过的最大的源文件，比如一个 30 GB 的源文件，它拥有所有数据，我会通过，是的，好的，好吧，我想这差不多就是这样了。哦，好的。
So we alluded to it earlier, but I think you have grand plans for our next recording, which we have to figure out the date, but we'll post it on our Google Plus page. Yeah, keep on the Google Plus page. We want to do a Q&A episode. We'll see how it works. I don't know yet.
所以我们之前提到了它，但我认为你对我们的下一次录音有宏伟的计划，我们必须弄清楚日期，但我们会把它发布在我们的 Google Plus 页面上。是的，保持在 Google Plus 页面上。我们想做一个问答环节。我们会看看它效果如何。我还不知道。
We haven't sort of fleshed out the details, if it'll be a Google Hangout. I think that'll be good. We have to figure out how to record it right so i don't want to have to just like read the like re-say what people are saying so we have to figure this out it'll be a good experiment for us to learn totally um maybe we can just record the hangout i think you can record a hangout we'll see we'll look into it and uh we'll figure out the exact format we'll let you know maybe we'll have a skype number and people can skype we'll have to do it somewhere crazy so we'll be okay we'll be somewhere crazy well we'll be somewhere we'll be
我们还没有充实细节，如果它会是一个 Google Hangout。我认为那会很好。我们必须弄清楚如何正确录制它，所以我不想不得不只是像读，像重述人们在说什么，所以我们必须弄清楚这一点，这对我们学习来说将是一个很好的实验，完全，嗯，也许我们可以只录制 Hangout，我想你可以录制 Hangout，我们会看看，我们会研究它，然后我们会弄清楚确切的格式，我们会让你知道，也许我们会有一个 Skype 号码，人们可以 Skype，我们必须在某个疯狂的地方做，所以我们会没事的，我们会，我们会，我们会
somewhere i don't know what to make crazy everywhere is crazy okay it's us you know so so uh we'll we'll do the show over hangouts uh you'll see our goofy faces should we if we record the hangout i guess we could just post the hangout as well in addition to the mp3 sure we'll figure out something but anyways we're gonna have you guys call in yeah we'll see if not we could just post the hangout as well in addition to the MP3. Sure, we'll figure out something. But anyways, we're going to have you guys call in. Yeah. We'll see. If not, we'll just talk about news, I guess. Yeah, yeah.
某个地方，我不知道什么叫疯狂，到处都是疯狂，好的，是我们，你知道，所以，嗯，我们会通过 Hangouts 做节目，你会看到我们傻乎乎的脸，如果我们录制 Hangout，我想我们也可以发布 Hangout，除了 MP3 之外，当然，我们会弄清楚一些事情，但无论如何，我们会让你们打电话进来，是的，我们会看看，如果没有，我们也可以发布 Hangout，除了 MP3 之外，当然，我们会弄清楚一些事情，但无论如何，我们会让你们打电话进来，是的，我们会看看，如果没有，我们大概就谈谈新闻吧，是的，是的。
Until people call in general. Like 90 minutes of news if you don't call in. Might be a short episode. But yeah, it will be a Q&A. Definitely post if certain days are good for you or times are good. We're curious to see sort of like what people's interest level is. So yeah yeah definitely post on the plus page and let us
直到人们打电话进来，通常。比如如果你不打电话进来，90 分钟的新闻。可能是一个简短的剧集。但是的，它将是一个问答。如果某些日子对你来说很好，或者时间很好，一定要发布。我们很好奇想看看人们的兴趣水平。所以是的，是的，一定要发布在 Plus 页面上，让我们
know what you think all right thank you all all right see you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
知道你的想法，好的，谢谢大家，好的，再见，片头音乐是 Biner Pilot 的 Axo，Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。